puis trois ans maintenant ouais d'autres
s'en rapprocher on peut s'en rapprocher
ce sera peut-être le cas on fait déjà
falloir gagner et espérer donc née
popperle mais voilà si les deux
conditions sont respectées
ça sera la délivrance well as des livres
adha on sera délivrée et mais du coup
peut-être les gens seront déçus parce
que pas de stream demain battant ping du
coup si vous voulez des stream
encourager les peaux ouais mais
encouragé max voilà voler des sacs demi
finale ouais
et si vous voulez et soul est juste vous
qualifiez pas avoir de stress du coup
y'a point s de quoi laisser un peuple
autres comme attitude que c'est un peu
plus être allé si on est courageux on
encourage max non mais quelque part le
scénario idéal fat ce serait quand même
une victoire de max sur nés pour deux
mines en pour bien bien déjà ce serait
la qualif dessus il y aurait une belle
demi avec un match à enjeu contre un
concurrent direct un truc ce serait se
serait ce serait peut-être le scénario
on va dire idéal mais bon va être
pleutre quand même temps et on va être
pour le scénario
non mais c'est pas quoi en 98 il préfère
une finale france brésil et la gagner
qu'affronter je sais pas quoi l'arabie
saoudite en finale quoi monter champion
du monde pareil ils savent pas le même
impact
c'est vrai aussi c'est vrai aussi c'est
vrai aussi plus le défi est grand plus
la victoire est belle à vaincre sans
péril on triomphe sans gloire en
triomphe quand même quoi voilà bon on
s'en fout pas à la con quoi je t'échange
les sommes dues à ces jeunes je sais que
sur le discorde ya un mec fantastique
qui est passé et alors il était très
énervé parce qu'ils jouent des parties
contre un autre mec du discorde web
habitués pleutre tu as une grosse pièce
de plus
bon je me dis que c'est une tour une
dame il a passé une pièce est battu et
change tout je ne trouve pas ça amusant
enfin il pense que c'est un ordinateur
du coup il a dit quoi
il a dit je joue quoi un être humain
jour est comme ça pour s'amuser comprend
banon et de musique où se trouve
toujours dans la victoire
paito dit non il te dit n'y a que des
ordinateurs que jouer comme ça c'est
très ennuyeux donc vain quelque part je
me contre toi quoi
ouais quelque part on peut dire que
c'est un peu comme les journaux à
l'époque
ouais tu changes les dames du coup je te
regarde pas tu es parti ne doit plus le
contre-torpilleur cas il était très déçu
il comprend pas cette attitude très peu
le train quelque part très peu très peu
l'autre mais bon bon ça peut gagner quoi
oui mais en fait c'est 10 à rangueil
d'accord chacun chacun son délire te dis
c'est pas amusant non mais c'est marrant
ça m'a fait sourire après je sais pas si
trop les parrains peut-être trop l'air
non non je pense que j'étais très très
sérieux attends je vais enlever les
notifs du téléphone je vérifier que tout
soit bien parti on a démarré un peu en
avance c'est aujourd'hui fab moi comme
ça
il me semble un peu parlé avant on
pourra déjà parlé pendant way au moins
pour pas que les gens ratent le début
quoi flo bibi qui est la jugeote à
florence je pense qu'il a tous les jours
à florence france elle et va peut-être
oui on dirait on a une petite touche de
fraîcheur des gens aussi sur youtube que
je vois jocelyn team n 32
philippe a pas mis en professeur pour
attac est ce que moi de chez moi je peux
avoir le double de chatou pas et je
crois pas que toi ok et je crois pas non
pas du coup désole jean sur youtube je
réponds mais tu vas sur mon est grande
ouais mais du coup de fouet sur ton
écran alors on le voit pas tout le temps
on va on va l'échiquier parce que bon
ouais en fait du coup pour commenter ce
qui avait partagé son écran je vois ce
poste chez lui mais c'est tout donc je
peux mettre un petit chat fenêtres et à
côté pour voir un peu aussi se pose en
chat mais du coup j'ai pas accès à tous
les tchats alors tu peux le mettre sur
le buzz sur le smartphone
par contre c'est ce que je fais moi
souvent quand je peux celui de youtube
du coup plutôt que de le mettre là
dessus parce qu'en fait tu khouyi pharma
s'il arrive il arrive un peu à
retardement je préfère le mettre sur le
smartphone mère d'un des volets de la
grande stratégie
je sais quand on veut conseil après
après c'est pas forcément facile de tout
avoir ouvert en même temps mais c'est
notre jeu mettre une petite fenêtre à
gauche le smartphone au milieu et le
shiatsu d'être à droite à kohler
commencent les games nous demande la
cuisse 44 à 14 heures donc on est venu
voilà un petit peu en avance comme on
l'a dit parce que c'est quand même une
journée très importante et comme c'est
un peu le temps que la notification
arrive que les gens arrivent on vous a
laissé un petit un petit quart d'heure
de battement mais en plus disons mais
pour les autres partir qu'on sait pas
quelle heure c'est par contre annoncé
c'est parfait je pense personne ne sait
non c'est à dire quand ils ont fini il
rejoue ouais ok je marque
donc du coup j'ai sur les réseaux
puisque ça des partis suivant les
parties ça peut être plus intéressant
les raisons encore qu'aujourd'hui avec
les rapides on aura du ce mais
aujourd'hui les choses la saison il y
aura un vainqueur marc webb 0,5
qui dit du spectacle aujourd'hui il y en
aura il y aura énormément de spectacle
mais maxime faut enfin dans tous les cas
là faut qu'ils gagnent indépendamment
donné peut donner poteau parce que même
si c'est ce qu'ils gagnent et maxime qui
perd c'est très dangereux lors il
manquera un point de bonus assauts nancy
maxime peur baude a encore des chances
de se qualifier mais faudra prier pour
que les autres ce plan et si tu en vises
un tour des stands main que d'espérer
que des mecs perdre
après y'a maso pour en dernier recours
ouais mais maso payer plus connu pour
son goût des chats noirs en fait oui
mais pas les chats noirs is est
justement les autres oui je viens de
secondes de jeu j'aime passer une soirée
avec toi yann ça va être une bonne
soirée t'inquiète pas ça va bien se
passer bien se passer une taille est pas
très belle soirée là on va se faire
ensemble
[Musique]
on verra on verra mais bon y'a maso à
l'an dernier recours pour aller pointer
tout le monde
enfin il fallait qu'il y ait enfin la
fin des parties longues
non mais ça reprend demain faut pas
crier victoire trop vite les amis
essebag ce qui passe le bonjour au club
d'échecs de marseille saluent le jeune
chef et yolande 6 km de gaines ce qu'ils
m'ont prié bas si yannick se gagnent il
s'est plié
si yannick qui joue dépôt c'est loin de
plier pour abattre les plans demi et
surtout qu'on l'a déjà dit mais dans
l'autre tableau le finaliste sera pas
forcément un gros génie ce sera
peut-être nos 20 ans sur deux et en plus
les pots est très pote avec car yakine
je crois que ce que je veux dire
d'ailleurs il va envoyer du lourd un
courrier kinnear oui c'est une partie
intéressante reste une belle partie
savait pas ump l on aurait peut-être
fait ça en résumé mais là on avait un
peu le on n'est plus trop la fois qua
non non sans un petit montage de ludwig
dollars ouais ça change un petit peu
aussi à
puisque c'est une partie entre
guillemets sans enjeu pour eux donc
c'est toujours c'est toujours spécial
quoi fabre non me cause tout simplement
posté une jolie partie
donc je vous le conseille sur les pas vu
monique florence y avait le foot on
serait passé en fait du match de foot
way n'est pas une très bonne soirée pour
toi non mais bon au delà de la défaite
que mal rentrés dans le match pas de
papa d'intention ou carton rouge après
un quart d'heure plateau d'al cieux wen
ont déjà vu une petite une petite
interview un petit hall capteurs match
sur winamax ils sont pas très confiant
pour ce inter je dis tout de suite le
confiant de gaulle pour la saison 1
oui mon jeu royan photo p ouais non mais
il te dit ils te disent ça va être long
moi mon gars on va te 20 pu aider là
pour bâtir le long terme lendemain donc
cette année y compris quand ils essayent
fait déjà des hauts des bas
déjà ça va bien mieux qu'il ya deux mois
donc il est repris l'équipe l'été
dernier quand même là bas à toi le
maintien tu te dis bon ça va aller qu'on
a déjà dix points d'avancé au maintien
vous pensiez printemps repenser
printemps et puis bah c'était l'hiver
quoi du coup elles vont cette année
coûteront pas viser grand chose après
bon tu sais jamais sicilienne de trois
matches de suite en fait charmant de vie
de faire le podium mais la petit coup de
mou des gens ne se sentent pas trop
dedans et puis je crois pas qu'on ait un
super effectif tout court à brady donc
voilà toulouse au fond du trou aussi
vers notre loup soit pas du tout nîmes
non plus toujours ni mme geneviève qui
est une petite pub pour notre club de
corrèze au village de 1200 habitants et
deux équipes une de n4 et une en
régionale 1
mais ça qu'on supporte mvl donc
l'attention la série club vous êtes loin
de brive ou pas mais ça que ce on espère
sera monté
cette année ou parce que ça joue le
titre les sacs jr jeff tu penses à joue
la montée en n3 là je sais pas en fait
mais pourquoi pas non mais c'est bien
qu'ils aient des quais des clubs comme
ça aussi dans des petits endroits aux
gens de jouer un peu de partout en
france qui soit pas que dans les grosses
villes ou quoi et que les villages bayer
des clubs d'échecs ou quoi c'est cool
quoi ça à côté de brive sa cote est de
règle dans que les mecs vont voir aussi
du rugby tu vois brive la gaillarde
je pense à j'imagine qui fait qui fait
une bonne saison à cette année ils sont
pas mal en top 14
ils ont battu le stade français l'a
dernier match à domicile ils sont plutôt
bien sont plutôt bien car elles n'ont
pas le niveau mais ils se maintiennent
tu vois bon maintenant il ya 1200 âmes
dans leur village ni un rouge qui me
stimule heureux enfin vu que lyon
c'était encore pire peut-être
ouais mais non enfin de vote je préfère
que voir santé gagner si lyon gagne et
gaudillat nippon leur vie quoi je serai
jugé réjouir du malheur des autres et tu
peux de charrier comme ça mais c'est pas
un vrai bonheur c'est plus de la
nuisance qu'autre chose et si les
devants en ligue 2 tu seras en sueur non
d'abord à des beaux derbys non mais nenê
en ligne de mire lyon en banque et là ça
va pas ils ont ils sont pas pris de
blessures horribles
du coup je crois que c'est une année
difficile pour eux mais ils vont aller
en ligue 2 n'ont plus à jour ils iront
bien si tu veux
il nous faut pour moins de 9 à 12 heures
pour info fabien occupait il ya trois
enfants d'une des anciennes camarades de
classe ils sont petits poussins et très
prometteur ok bakool bas passez le
bonjour à la maman alors on ne sait pas
où on ne sait pas ce que ça cache pas
qu'il a vraiment fait non je pense que
j'ai une idée du coup je suis pas sûr
que c'est peut être
édicte je lâche parce que c'est bien
elle ou pas quoi mais tu ne sais pas je
ne sais pas je suis pas sûr mais il nous
dit d'uploader qui passe le bonjour
mercredi alors est ce qu'elle est sortie
la vidéo wailly cariat qui énorme on va
pas le faire oui car yakine on vous fait
pas toutes les parties non plus enfin on
fait des belles parties mais oui car
yakine c'était une belle partie sans non
plus être un chef-d'oeuvre dans fab non
c'était juste sympa et le seul truc en
fait c'est que ok certaines parties de
maxime ont leur est faite évidemment
mais là en fait c'est un peu un match ça
que l'un ou l'autre gagne le tournoi où
ça s'est mis maintenant ça change pas
leur dis ouais c'est juste une belle
partie mais dans ces cas là je pense
généralement on préfère faire des
vieilles parties du cou jolie pour ce
faire notre culture générale si c'est
vraiment une partie de foot pourquoi pas
mais là en fait c'était juste vraiment
pas mal mais je sais pas quand j'en
avais préféré ou faire l'a fait partie
de sa reach par exemple avec la tour où
les cinq qui ont des trucs comme oui
vraiment exceptionnel en là c'était une
belle partie sans non plus être un
chef-d'oeuvre
non mais ils ont envoyé quoi c'était pas
si pire c'était pas pleut trop du tout
parents de la petite la petite seule la
petite séquence tactique elle pourrait
tomber dans la sélection du mois tu vois
ça c'est possible ça c'est précieux
ça peut tomber dans la sélection du mois
mais après faire une vidéo
spécifiquement là dessus c'est sais pas
non mais ça rit ça et tu vois ça aurait
était né peau contre sow peut-être tu as
dans le sens où il ya un vrai enjeu
lasser il manque un peu l'enjeu quoi et
du coup il ya ce bloc avant le choc
soyaux toi y'a du manga du monde dans le
tchat les meilleurs sont là mais j'ai
bien j'ai donné mon prénom dire tu
savais qu'ils s'étaient qui d'autre a
alors sans être anti pleutre prix merkel
shevell ne faisait pas tout pour battre
andreikin aurait-il les épaules pour
défier carlo scène de toute façon il n'a
pas trop le choix il va pas faire exprès
de perdre
non mais faut battre andy keane mais
piola donc de toute façon il va il va
tout donner pour le battre il va pas se
dire oui peut-être je suis plus autres
je me fais limin et pour regarder 6 ou
quoi se qualifieront ça donne ça devoir
dans deux minutes fab
on va regarder en priorité à andré qui
de maxime et on jettera un oeil sur
saône et pommiers h et aussi parce que
parce que parce que parce que les
matches sont quand même plus ou moins
liés entre guillemets surtout en cas de
victoire de maxime exactement j'ai envie
de dire motif du moment ça va saigner
aujourd'hui pas nul pas de quartiers pas
de prisonniers mais après on fait dans
tous les cas c'est mieux
que se passe en fait à vrai dire oui
parce que so il leur avait pas le choix
d'aller gagner jusqu'au bout il doit
prendre un bonus nepos se trouve juste
aller en finale ça pourrait lui suffire
je serai meilleur but s'il va joindre x
line donc non mais clairement clairement
clairement clairement c'est dans nos
intérêts que se gagnent dans tous les
cas appui en plus si sow gayet
maximilian c'est déjà fini
donc dans tous les cas vaut mieux que ça
gagne mais mais ça n'empêche que ça
serait pas finie pour autant du tout du
tout bah dis donc c'est si celle ci sans
fins aussi doit jouer en dhr équine en
2000 et willy admettons en finale
admettons en un point de bonus sur les
deux matches c'est pas impossible non
seclin parce qu'andré qu'il peut bien le
planter avec les blancs je pense pas
j'ai réussi plan de sa prépa avec les
blancs il peut bien le bon allez trève
de plaisanterie fab du génial tandja
aucunement de son nez là où sur twitch
u20 l'a donc l'ipl sur youtube va tous
être partout on y est on est on est
partout on est des deux côtés
après le chat which on le voit plus
facilement mais voilà mais on jette un
peu en a de partout et eisenberg
ils nous demandent si des blitz est pas
vraiment faim pas encore c'est du rapide
25 minutes ils en font deux pour
l'instant donc samat aller-retour une
partie blanc une partie noire si un
vainqueur c'est fini on a qualifié et si
un partout et bien ce sera des cadences
plus rapide 10 minutes puis 5008 suis
dit que c'était un axe texte alors pour
une qualification dès aujourd'hui il
faudrait quand même vais le gagner
connais peut perdre mais ça c'est la
version de l'autre ça c'est la version
peut être là la vraie version à mon avis
c'est vrai t'as raison c'est ce que tu
disais en début de romance émission
c'est la 2em veine l'epo je pense que
c'est en gros si tu es vraiment
supporters que tu aime les grands
matches ce que tu as envie de voir bon
allez ça a démarré dans une minute fab
on va on va complètement se mettre dans
la partie face à devrait avoir commencé
une minute plus tôt on va vraiment se
mettre dans la partie et se demander
qu'est ce que tu penses andré quines
avec les blancs ils vaquent ce qui va
tenter
finalement est-ce qui va jouer sa trompe
offs qui sa mémoire est tout de même ce
resort où un système de londres un petit
machin sa place
oui et il a le zébu surtout pas de façon
maxime sur des cartes fera cavalier si
ça c'est sûr et tu ferais fou g5 des
cinq cavaliers des deux têtes cette
petite variante la la mode mois de
travail il joue pas mal jean structure
je sais pas faire ça après il peut jouer
n'importe quel petit machin
bon alors il a fait que 4 c 5 cavalli
ces trois des six cavaliers deux
cavaliers f6 bon soin des captures
transpose soit tu fais jetteront donc
des cas tu transpose parce qu'après
pions prend cavaliers prend à 6 on
rentre dans une major fab exact soit
homo tu fais j'ai trop c'est autre chose
ah oui la phase iii pour préparer g4 fab
le joueur russe qui suit les bonnes
chaîne
j'enregistre eux c'est le nom que machin
collingwood sf3 non oui il avait joué à
froid dans cette position il souffrirait
il a fait un jeu 3d c'est marrant parce
que sur assist je peux faire des cats
est transposée oui mais c'est pas son
idée en fait il veut une bonne version
de je pense qu'il veut ça vraiment et 4
ou détroit donc bon c'est intéressant -
les jeux un petit machin comme rennes et
on m'a demandé si j'avais mangé mon
avocat ouais ils étaient mangées
je me suis fan avocat toast donc faire
après ce coup h3 qu'est-ce que pas faire
les noirs et ce qui va jouer g6 battue
peut tout voir en photo tu peux faire je
décide tu peux faire cas ici si tu veux
faire un six tu peux faire peut-être 2,5
paraissent que son idée surgit ici ce
serait jouer des 4 puis on prend
cavaliers prend et jouer à dragon ou de
phase iii bat pourquoi pas mais c'est
pas ouf
mais après toujours faire g3 foulée de
cette variante je peux faire mais c'est
pour ça que je dis en fait tout est
jouable 1
là il faut il faut surtout comprendre
femme qu'elle transposition tu souhaite
obtenir avec les noirs ouais ouais c'est
ça dépend de ce qu'il veut et
outil voir on nous dit c'est pas ouf les
dragons avec h 3 mai oui mais rien et
aux fumées ou sport tu sors les noirs
enfin maxime de la neige d'or déjà et
puis là tu ferais g3 jarre fou g7
enfin g7 g3 rock ou g2 voilà en tout cas
alors que na waie décemment c'est ce
qu'a laissé situe peut bouffer au 5
octobre
[Musique]
je vais juste arrivé à fouet trois pour
montrer que le courage 3 au final ils
étaient 1,8 m et quand bien même
toujours accueilli des deux bon je pense
que trois c'est bien mais combien lui
ferait qu'aider de haut le cloud 3 c'est
aussi pas si bête parce que j'ai avec g4
des fois donc les f4 et les cinq journée
allégée ce à quoi bon ok là je crois
c'est juste pas dessus révolution en
tout cas fabre on peut dire un choix
d'ouverture malin côté russe puisqu'il a
il est bien moins préparés que maxime
dans les ouvertures et il réussit dans
ce match en rapide a joué un petit coup
certes sans prétention mais qui fait qui
fait réfléchir le joueur français mais
nous applaudir un joueur russe qui quand
même dans ce match dans les ouvertures
jusqu'ici aura tout de même réussi à
performer quoi web ont alors pris hier
en finir avec les blancs et larry page
spécialement taillé à tenter un truc
c'est de vite donné nul il n'est pas
vraiment arriver à mettre de pression
mais en tout cas son choix de la
française était avéré bon bon gars avec
l'éventuel âgées mais le risque de
perdre et aujourd'hui bah écoute on
priait faisant on verra le stade la
partie aussi ce que ça t'a n'a souvent
on peut juger en fonction du résultat
mais c'est pas idiot de parents très
directement la grande théorie qu'en
témoignent à préparer clan adverse à de
se jeter dans la gueule du loup français
ok donc maxime âge de jouer que ça qui
l'interdît id4 vu que les ballons pas
fait il dit non et ça ressemble pas mal
aux trucs de quinssaines
anti-chasse nikov genre tu peux montrer
4 c 5 cavaliers 3kg et 6kg c325 j'avais
notamment une partie réelle carte scène
la différence c'est que là au moins ton
ful f1 peut sortir
oui dans ses versions locales ont glissé
à 2 h 3 pour penser j'ai cape may maxime
du coup ce match va vite il est pas mal
réfléchi pour son set up maintenant on y
faire un tour
est-ce que du coup les blancs voire un
plan genre fou j'ai 2 kg 3 f 1 et 3
alors peut-être où tu joues juste ouafqa
trop sinon ouais position puissions
intéressante fab qui va pouvoir même
ressembler à des gens alors de loin mais
à des genres est indienne s'est
peut-être que tu veux fermer avec les
blancs faudra faire attention
en gros si ça ressemble à quelque chose
c'est le système un peu des anglaises
bonne unique adversaire
oui complètement et avec les blancs
jouent un peu comme s'ils avaient les
noirs mais tu as déjà fait j'ai 80 ou de
faire j'ai trois plis g4 un jour et les
noirs en fait quand ils jouent ce set up
l'idéal c'est pas qu'il y ait six fosses
de ses cavaliers dos a touché cette
cavale cette fois ci la halle aux toiles
mais celui là aussi non batum tient bien
le sens mais comme samantha des f-5 déjà
engagé six coups g7 et oui tu peux soit
rejoué a exclu l'an en sept pour jouer à
gafsa coup celui là on le sait est aussi
un humaniste le faire pour jouer fouet
si ces dessins qui nous attend mais tu
as besoin de cette case de 7 pour un
cavalier oui c'est vrai et le faux e set
alors peut-être du coup que sur gk jesse
saurait était aussi une option mais du
coup les cheveux et me batte à peut-être
pas le temps de faire taire a lieu cette
fois aussi ceux des 5 pascal et g5 qui
rôdent quoi peuvent-ils vite en tout cas
donc il ya eu fou j'ai 2 h 5
donc il laisse pas vivre le plancher 4
évidemment j'ai cinq cavaliers h 7 h 4
ok 6 je dire mais bon pour garder calme
est de 33 arrêts qui est thématique qui
attaquerait le curage 5 donc là il ya
deux écoles je pense que sur foucher 4
fabia f3 puis cavale et prend h57 enfin
donc la deuxième école ce serait g6
exacte elle parle
bah ouais mais bon si tu schiffer zdf
flottille de gagnage 4 après faut
regarder s'il était prêt à prendre un
grand drap de satin calais sac à merde
me à j-6 en outre à oui mais à cali des
sarko si tu payes des cinq jeux fois je
crois femme âgée 6 allée de son fonds
pardon pas parce que je suis ici c'est
beaucoup plus fort je n'ai pas vu que
sur wii mais tais toi ta peau qui fit
mesdames et 4 du forsc avait lui aussi
c'est dur commence pourquoi paroissiale
18 noms n'ont que des cinq romans mais
du coup kg 3g 6 bouffe bouffe bouffe roi
là cavalier des cinq ans premier
admettons d'objets dans lequel
esthétisme qui dit qu'après 4 ça me fait
hyper père femmes bah en fait si l'on se
repasse ses shows on n'a pas leur dire
les mecs donc peut-être qu'il y ait des
quatre c'est fort
et même un truc comme ça mais là on se
fait avoir beaucoup notamment d'un bon
on n'est pas plus autres mais kevin
tourmente par exemple peut-être fait roi
des huns des coups comme sa position est
bizarre journée à bakou d'ordi pour se
donner un avis car dj 6 kg 5 du coup là
bien de gisborne et c'est aussi ce qui
est des cinq oreilles c'est tellement
plus facile avec l'ordi tu pousses le
pion et donc cavalier g 3g six cavaliers
h 5 min pranger 5e quel propos monsieur
âgé qu'à rallier prend bon c'est du show
c'est juste très chaud elle est là alors
dit john kerry des cinq mais je pense
pas qu'ils soient préparés andré kind
ans est sur cette position prédit donc
prendre 5 pour prendre comme de juste
l'eni permis de séjour bonne vers notre
hymne parce qu'avec les mots justes la
dame vers 20 h 5 et c'est la cata on
étudie camaïeu set et ça va mais il faut
juger 14 non non ça je peux comprendre
l'arc
non mais là oui je comprends maintenant
mais jusqu'au oui il ya ça aussi
d'ailleurs on évite heures début des
jeux 2 5 buts à 1 formation difficile
cavaliers g3 est peut-être for
information positive
c'est pas une prépa et j'ai envie de
dire tant mieux parce que sinon ça va
bien se passer un ces chauffards fable
c'est une partie tu vois c'est la partie
qu'on attendait pour se chauffer on en
discute ensemble au téléphone on n'avait
pas eu jusqu'à maintenant tu vois de la
belle grosse opposition des doigts on
n'avait pas eu du poutine en pasqua non
content topalov tué deux nuls et après
c'était facile à presque oui mais voilà
la balance est très facile un endroit
qui ne va me le jeu non mais on sent on
sent on sent on sent de la puissance de
poutine en face à l'om ait utilisant le
poutine c'est petit côté russe mais tu
sais d'ailleurs que j'ai vu il ya un jeu
vidéo qui est sorti sur steam et
s'appelle poutine style et c'est à dire
que là en fait à des puzzles et on va
arrêter c'est que des puzzles ou il ya
poutine dessus tu vas pas te taper en
fait des sources à mains nues c'est pas
ça le but du jeu non le but du jeu c'est
que tu dois recréer en forme de puzzle
des photos de poutine donc
automatiquement j'ai très envie
d'acheter le jeu pour le faire sur un
stream c'est des puzzles forcément très
intéressant vous tu te retrouves
toujours à la fin avec la gueule de
poutine dessus donc forcément un puzzle
calme un peu au dessus de tout philippe
chasse aux nantis piolenc c'est vraiment
le truc c'est que soient obligés en fait
donc c'est pour ça qu'on regarde et kg 3
qui attire l'oeil pour l'attaqué à cinq
forcément g6 qui paraît forcée voilà et
les blancs doivent aller pour pour
sacrifier quelque chose hors soirée
classique
non mais t'as plein plein d'options
c'est hyper chaud mais qu'ils restaient
pas mais peut-être tu dois laisser faire
payer 10 5
ouais [ __ ] s'échauffent à me faisait
peur f4 tu as plein de coups
c'est chaud femmes femmes femmes c'est
chaud du slip c'est chaud du slip fab on
jette un oeil à l'autre partie juste
pour détendre un peu calé blanc c'est
son jeu mais qu'est ce qu'ils en fassent
une anglaise au cecos et une anglaise ça
semble aller pour les ponots l'ordi
donne plus ou moins égales on voit la
dame en b3 les trucs qui s'échangent les
peaux qui doit avoir essayé d'échanger
des singles foncé 3 et embêter un peu
que la structure le pardon isolé d'alpha
mos
bon bah oui tout savoir sur le tueur
isolé
vous savez vous pouvez trouver tout ça
mais ça épate à trouver cadets vladan
fait un très bon dvd donc une série de
vidéos et ça vaut le coup j'ai quasiment
tous regardé je peux encore au bout mais
j'ai dû faire douze vidéos sur les 16 ou
et alors tu as appris des trucs vraiment
no fake ou pas non mais c'est vrai que
tu ressens je me dis tu vas te regarder
une deuxième fois parfois ou pas bah je
pense que vient de le faire une fois de
son temps bon là pour le coup je pense
tellement une vitesse de limoges fa fa
fa fa mauvaise nouvelle on a
complètement oublié g6 intermédiaire
cavalia fille de cavalli g3
étrange et 6 5 ap west roaillan didonne
bon c'est pas facile à penser en amont
mais oui c'est bien jouer et quand il
prend 5,5 quoi tu fais pas ça trop
rapide bref cette wii mais en fait ça
depuis deux mois je pensais que ça lui
plaisait mais faut être soi c'est très
fort un maillot après c'est très
rentable voire frustrant mais bon une
fois qu'ils pensent ça paraît logique
vaste comme d'hab avec l'ordi en fait il
n'y a rien d'aussi dur parce que c'est
pas énorme de ouf mais oui tu passes le
foot va activer tu veux prendre h 50 m
le fou angers 4 et enfin on ne dit plus
0,9 pour andré keane c'est justement à
cause de cette variante là mais il va
pas l'avoir parce que fait froid c'est
trop dur
il a un bon je sais pas il peut voir il
est fort le mec
mais en fait c'est louis camellini non
mais en fait juste pour dire bon déjà ce
que rapide t'as pas tout le temps tu
pour réfléchir et à beaucoup de coups
qui sont tentants donc un mais trois pas
être qu'à croquer des symboles mission
et au kg si ce machin jeunes en fait tu
vas pas le temps de tout ce qui est à
fond donc il faut faire un choix dans
qu'elle faisait on s'attend et là-dessus
kg 3 probablement non mais c'est très
compliqué une opposition
j'aimais enfin je dois dire que c'est
plutôt pas mal pour maxime genre de
partie du board à nick wey vous faites
là lors des jeunes donnent moins un pour
les ça continue comme ça l'ordinateur
d'un jacques gagnon pour les noirs mais
bon ça va t'on on peut se tromper je
sais pas trop compliqué pour être un
vrai avis sur la position c'est très
très chaud jacques hayé des cinq ça va
on nous propose fou j'ai qu'un réfugié
car je pense qu'il ya toujours f3 et de
toute façon comme les blancs veulent
jouer f4 je pense pas que ce soit
vraiment l'idée du siècle non femmes
n'ont pas pour l'instant on dit - 0,1
oui non mais là là c'est très difficile
après forcément ça favorise maxime c'est
j'ai envie de te dire là on est dans un
duel ses terres battues genre nadal
ferrer c'est chaud mais c'est toujours
nadal qui a le dessus
donc là on tend à penser que maxime
puisses puis sort le dessus donc ça a
échangé angers 5 a pas eu qu'à loger
trois intermédiaires et maintenant on
s'attend probablement un g6 une prise
angers 5
tout est jouable en fait non à tout et
je te jure ce que j'ai ici aussi f4
peut-être qui rôde c'est très compliqué
non mais tout cela c'est hyper compliqué
et je pense que très vite fin dans deux
trois minutes on va voir beaucoup plus
clair mais les gens ont beaucoup
beaucoup de choix donc voir f4 au
prochain fab pour les blancs si le pion
ne se protègent pas je pense insurgés
six f4 ça paraît quand même ultra
logique non mais le truc tu peux
peut-être vous fait gagner cinq minutes
mais bon mais bon peu tu as peur ces
trois des quatre saisons maintenant le
sujet on peut pas rentrer je peux lâcher
aucune info c'est c'est le bordel mais
ça c'est des vrais échecs tu ne peux pas
pleutre andré quitte je pense qu'il est
venu pour s'amuser de façon fabi jour
rien il est venu au dernier moment ils
jouent contre ivey est je pense qu'il a
juste il est juste venu se faire plein
en fait le gars oui bon produit mais je
ne sais pas un petit qui éprouvent un
design aussi une option
on leur dit adore les noirs mais ça veut
rien dire bon votre logique si tu fais h
4 h troc lennar tu m'appelles et blanc
bes sas tu pousses tourbillon passé tu
prend l'espace
quand tu as un oncle et blanc ferait
n'importe quand je sais pas mais c'est
parfois à l'ouest ça aucun sens avec à
l'étranger 5 ça a l'air fort mais bon ok
c'est juste vraiment chaud mais j'aime
bien le pion h
my blog bon pour un ton papa de fuji 4
passes qu'adam grand mais ça sent le
rentrer dans un truc comme ça
non ça c'était très chaud très chaud
même noté défaut g4 qui marche du coup
il ya plus d'un mois
ouais compliqué en métal et damas casque
sur dame 17 a peut-être qui sait satine
non mais c'est ok mais je suis assez
confiant pour maxime parce que c'est son
genre pression ou c'est très compliqué
il peut juste calcul est à fond ben
ouais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi ce qui du coup correspond bien à son
style
ça aurait pu être ultra dangereux par
ses charmes ultra-dangereux composition
messi 6e américaines et ouvrir des à
leur niveau je mets un petit truc pour
partager sur twitter fab nous les donner
un petit coup de main et partager sur
twitter gmail ou encore facebook où
partout en fait voilà j'ai mis quelques
liens twitter du coup donc mais avec à
l'étranger 5 à l'efa bon on y va il est
ok du coup la menace des north h4h 3
gmail et blanc doivent très vite radio
receveur jeff cadre duquel j 3 je ne
sais pas un truc comme ça et génois 4
ouais tu pars de la bande en tout cas
d'autres effets carré lieu ces trois au
clash 4h catway c'est sûr mais ce qu'on
regarde ta langue grecque h4 et b5 et on
adoré les noirs comme les kabyles 500
franchement tu vas y tu vas aller
prendre une kalach comme ouais mais ça
ressemble vraiment pas un truc qu'il
faut faire oui oui mais tant mieux
visuellement ce vraiment mauvaise
joueuse sur notre faim je ne sais pas
pourquoi il aurait un fish sept minutes
pour partir se vendent au bape fait
qu'il est nul quoi tu vas tu as le droit
d'être ville et au final sa préparation
j'ai envie de te dire tant h 4 escanaux
coûté 8,5 la f4 maintenant ça fait
puissance tout à l'heure on pouvait
faire cavalier prend un f4 là le camion
c3 qu'est-ce qui fait après tatin et
prendre cette dame province est qui est
des cinq dames 10 8
bon si je viens pas le nombre oui c'est
à est fou pranger 5
mais madame prend que c'est sympa mais
ça va peut-être être fini très vite fab
andreikin andré keane qui est en train
de nous laisser la place ben que ça
pousse toi et demi mais attendrait keane
et son copain nepomniachi qui sut aux
fables les rousses coffre à sueur
poutine poutine doit pas être content là
à mon avis il pourrait recevoir un appel
du président de la russie si ça continue
allez au goulag
ils vont finir comme time and of pas ben
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
préparation
je n'ai jamais vu ça où es-tu kramnik
avec ton sirius quoi vous et le conte
qui s'occupait de cyrus envoyé le mois
non mais bon on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas fabre je sens les jeux sans poutine
en sueur ce qu'une bonne
belle pour de bon quoique est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle que poutine su
pour qui que ce soit je ne suis pas sur
mon match 4 c'est ultra logique fable de
toute façon tant vidalon h3 et a envie
de protéger ton pions j'ai six fois au
monde un autre coup logique ce système
est bâti h4 marche je vais pas me
concernant je serai pas autant le faire
mais j'ai si c'est clairement un goût tu
peux faire dire oui on me jette ton plus
il a joué g6 ok mais je peux comprendre
bat pas on rappelle en fait que ce qui
semble pas bon et que j'ai ce ticket
pour le stade d'un procès qui est des
cinq dames 18 francs g5 may adam prend
mes cahiers ça tu sais on s'en fout
parce que roy davis qui prend un vide
dans le projet de ce genre de tacle à
tout retour en f1 où je peux quoi il
faut g4 qui arrive ça se sent et juste
unique et voilà donc que c'est une
maxime de dire moi j'avais en plus je le
défends pendant que j'avais alors qu'à
rallier prend dame prend car l'idée
d'aménager coûte 4 mai au quai puis on
prend tous les blancs les blancs voient
c'est un grand compliment ou d'homme je
sais pas où me donne quelque part un
grand mécène
oui mais juste de mesdames n'est donc
pas non mais je sais et regarde le redis
le radi propose un truc incroyable
ingerop du mais quoique introuvable
introuvable petit rock logique aussi
c'est foutu pourquoi pas fou prend 2,5 à
5 dam des deux fous j'ai quatre
peut-être mais bon peu importe quelles
sont les autres options pour
pour les blancs et skf 4 direct une
option aussi bref on prend un f4 et
peut-être qu'à evian réussissent et
quantifie cavaliers cette dame recettes
qui est des cinq qui donne plus de 20
mais qu'est ce d'autre 4 sinon on va
dire non mais faut taper souffre a taclé
bien su le faire avec quatre passes en
fait c'est un mauvais fond de base mais
dès que tu as 2 5 qui change c'est un
fou qui revit c'est devant la structure
et faire mal donc les pro 7 puisqu'elle
est 5ème tempo scam logique car si c'est
un truc
en fait voilà c'est un peu le principe
du cavalier est superflu en fait les
deux cavaliers demande la même case des
donc c'est un qui soit 2 comme ça un
petit temps mais un et l'autre india je
sais c'est un peu comme au foot
si tu mets giroux et un autre en quoi le
tour eiffel avec lui un palmarès ça sert
à rien la médiation une trentaine de la
tête que cela mais si tu mets giroud
griezmann mba paix chebaa giroud il fait
des déviations de la tête soit en
retrait pour pour griezmann soit en
profondeur pour pour kilian quoi mais tu
mets pas tu mets pas giroux un autre
grand qui s'est pas marqué en fait faire
annuler quoi si tu mets de l'argent
région non non valeur germain il
jouerait bien et kamba paix ou quoi
ironise plus tôt mais chassez comme
germain et mitroglou savait pas vraiment
ensemble mais il est plausible en main
mais il est bon en déviation if tu y as
tu la gagnes couleurs je crois que c'est
celui qui joue à une médiane kohler et
peter crouch jermain taylor joue à
monaco il à dortmund avant mais je crois
qu'il a fait une petite saison à cannes
dans le club des génies ouais tu vas tu
avril si john carr ou non qui joua un
dunk lors où andy carroll ton iphone
était bon agent car au bail était pas
mal et à ses techniques pour sa taille
bon après je vais pour un club pas très
strictes à jean avec grand effort comme
vous d'automne c'est quelque chose à
zlatan est mais l'attaquant fait il peut
aller bien avec tous les automnes n'a
besoin de personne
lucie joue tout seul bon en tout cas
pour l'instant ça échange 7 qui est des
cinq d'amd vite et maintenant avec les
blancs donc soif cad soit une faute
roche sais pas si con position très
compliquées seize minutes pour les deux
joueurs m'ont landry king qui réfléchit
donc maxime qui prend le lead quand même
à la pendule ça peut être important fab
c'est vrai mais bon c'est encore les
gros problème je rappelle que fout g4
c'est pas trop un coup pour l'instant
que cela me rend fou
enfin c'est hollande je veux dire mais
fou g4 c'est pas un coup à regarder ce
qu'adam cran et concret entre 38 et du
coup les blancs récupère la dame qui
aurait gagné une pièce dans la bataille
va voir d'eux-mêmes en fait un peu sale
rasht donc pas touché 4 1 c'est pas
simplement mes jetons avec une option
ouest 4 direct ou f4 fab fabre on a tous
les coups du tennis
c'est ce que vous faisiez you 5 c'est
logique celui là plus beauf du coup la
tête du gouffre et dames les dames le 2
c'est un coup la note que si fou g4
c'est pas si bon c'est un peu notre
agenda n'est ce pas qu'on a mené de
pronostic d'abord j'ai juste éviter fou
g4 en fait il fait fou gecaj enfin
vraiment gênant mesdames c3 ses formes
mais je considère vraiment petit rock
non mais ça va te cacher c'est un peu
grand bivouac en fait ouais t'es là non
je suis là mais toqué si ce qui arrive
c'est une menace sa guigne kg 5 et comme
ces 3,5 ou non mais c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est chaud ces belles parties
quand même un nom mais sa femme tu as et
pour des parties comme ça qu'on garde
les échecs des heures et des heures à
regarder des trucs qui servent à rien là
sérieux c'est the game avoir quoi
l'aller les gars qui sont là franchement
les mecs vous assurez vous êtes là pour
pour les baux échec ça envoie du jeu
bravo bravo deux ans bravo à maxime et
rendre ici pour le spectacle qui est
offert parce que là c'est vrai que ça
envoie sans voix c'est vers fab
alors est ce qu'on va voir aussi un peu
la solidité mentale de maxime qui est
mis aux tests là quand même un dans
cette partie ouais mais
et mieux comme ça dans ce stade je veux
dire c'est un test
en fait tu es obligé de répondre parce
que c'est pas la faire des sentiments à
réfléchir battage une personne tellement
compliqué que tu penses que ça derrière
une tremblay ben non en train de te dire
oui et ce que je joue secoue un peu
risqué où je suis là pour assurer la
nuit le sait après celle enfin là comme
ça tu le creusement de vous faire
n'importe quoi dans ta tête là juste
pour moi c'est le bordel tu dois tout
rodez concret n'a été pas de verser
enfin on va en juste un petit afficheur
nepomniachi le pion isolé dépôts qui
l'attirent mais il s'en sort s en sort
les possesseurs de l'epo qui défend et
qui va et qui va remettre un peu plus de
pression sur les épaules du joueur
français fab
mais bon le joueur français à se moquer
ni poupe
en fait je pense que c'est pas plus
inquiétant pour maxime piolot de passes
lui donne juste passer sa partie est
peut-être une bonne nouvelle à au bout
mais n'a en gros si hyper il est pas
tranquille que swan et pau qui passe ou
so we may encore moins christie ses
défauts ses mots si ces sauts je dirais
qu'il est encore en bon 60% de chances
de passer six aînés peau je pense qu'il
passe à 25% bon année pour andré qui
n'en 2 me ça va bien se passer un à mon
avis n'est pas il ya un ascendant
psychologique sur sur andré keane match
important il y a le président de la
russie qui va être derrière ces places
aux coups de fil que l' attention favori
dans le chatt grosse attaque sur le roi
blanc
ouais non
gros safarian la taille de moins tout le
monde va se faire attaquer il ya coup il
dit je regarde même si je comprends bien
t'inquiète nous non plus on comprend
rien frères prof profit laxatifs vie et
dire que dépôt a rien fait contre galles
fendrait mais on en parlait tu te
rappelles le roland garros nadal se fait
dominer par isner au premier tour et il
élimine tout le monde derrière ils
gagnent facile
je sais pas la grèce à l'euro on en a eu
des exemples comme ça de deux
compétitions où une équipe a beaucoup de
mal au premier tour elle montre rien et
puis après avec la confiance qui
s'engrangent ça enchaîne quoi donc
attention cavaliers vii joué par maxime
maxime qui reculaient kg contre la casse
donc peut-être f5 fab qui on prend un f5
f4 c'est l'idée de du joueur français
wall street qui chute de 5 à relief
cette le relève la tête juste créé un
mur est ok très bien et donc f5
pyon jin f on reprend encore qui
ouvrirait la diagonale du fou et la
flore on est cinq tours prend h5
bombarder sans flamme s'est pas flamand
le problème en fait c'est concrètement
c'est dans la main lost a pas d'âme 17
yekhlef 6 si tu fais tout aussi ce il te
dis juste fou 3 il va faire grand cas
ils sont en général moins met à la paire
de chou et étampes est ok c'est très
dangereux
ça c'est dans mon style et j'ai trouvé
ça j'aurais senti sage enfin si j'ai
cette fin j'ai pas la cas les capacités
de calcul de le voir fabien soyons bien
d'accord oui si tu mets cette position
là devant les yeux votre vie que dan
gens parce que cav a lieu sept cavaliers
six dames 17 et qui a valu six et à la
casse c'est cette dame à saint qui a
coûté 2 et je veux juste bouger mon fou
même en d2 rock et tour f1 et montréal
j'ai deux jours passés à mons rangée de
femmes non mais c'est assez logique
twingo est ce qui est expirée autre
chose de logique 2 11e
c'est moi qui revient juste pour voir la
pression du cf presque ont envie de le
faire sans mettre ce sujet de ce nom
mais non mais t'as pas envie il va ni
joue pour cent en fait tout pour ça donc
f5 c'est hyper logique qui on prend et
puis on prend et il n'y a pas d'âme g5y
ap adam h katia padam f6 et surtour g8
bon je fous 4
ouais maxime qui est peut-être en train
de se mettre en danger et fab cavaliers
f7 j'ai pas trop aimé le g6 cavaliers
afsset un petit peu un petit peu en
dedans quand même hein tu disais il est
obligé de jouer de jouer pour mettre la
pression de jouer pour gagner peut-être
que il hésite et il recule je trouve le
joueur français à fab ici non médecin
qui se c'est fort de ce truc sur vos
spirit qui regardent gf tourache 5 twh
soit 204 4 il avait ça va pas et qui
voit ses prisons il peut leur atefat
buggé côté carey nepomniachi montlaur
didonne avantages et et il tente tout
rejet mais auquel on préfère avoir les
blancs mais non c'est nul c'est quand
même important d'autant plus vraiment
6,6 à andry king qui va en demi contre
sceaux je pense qu'on reste quand même
gros favoris encore bon fab
on fait quoi on souffle on flippe ont
vomi n'y ont fait quoi parce que là on
flippe un f5 on attend de voir et on
nous gave 5 g ça passe par f5 g55 et g5
ça va être un pion perdu et le pire
c'est la catastrophe
je reste confiant je pense que maxime
invoqué à tort qu est ce que tu joues
aussi parce qu'en fait les coûts
candidats par f5 médecin coûte en regard
des 5 jouer nous attend mais je sais pas
céder sa sauce et gars qui le dit alors
il a fait chez fft peau hâlée maxime web
et du coup ces choses là mais peut-être
qu'il ya des quatre tours quand je sens
que ça va partir ce sens que je vois que
je me prends de l'autre le même et je
vais aller tant qu'elles sachent
encaissa j'encaisse agents qu'elle
supporte ces deux enquêtes la bouche je
prends ça va faire réfléchir ce qu'une
un truc qui finit liban ça donne envie
de rentrer dedans de façon avec les
blancs
et ouais mais alors des dida match est
en fait c'est juste vous jeter une pièce
où tu as vraiment pas ses dirigeants le
cavalier il va repartir tu m'as déjà de
récupérer une pièce
oui mais quand même c'est que laurent
plus de caisses de 8,6 et si c'était
envisagé du fou j'ai deux patronymes
garde fab ça pue et on attend après
l'école nationale aurélie ces deux mots
bien tu vas dire avec le cdmm balance en
votant oui mais est-ce que visuellement
c'est plus dur à comprendre ça bon ok
bien f1 finalement pas un va te tuer
enfin je t'en fous tu as raison non il
est tour j'ai vite 5 où se retranchent
cinq banques et des 4,35 pour lui parce
que tu enlèves les premiers 8e ans je
crains c'est pas brillant
c'est ça c'est ça l'idée c'est sur le
seul coup qu'il est un avantage pour les
blancs c'est d'amener de bons trouvable
parce qu'en fait elle me doit défendre
ton fous moi tu m'aurais des rois f12
pourquoi mai prochain ouais mais attends
c'est loin d'être clair ça bah oui
pourquoi on peut prendre 25 ok mais ça
s'est jointe est clair tout ce qu'ils
n'ont mais ok non mais t'es pas facile
enfin c'est ok c'est objectivement mieux
pour les blancs de loin gagnants fautes
mais non non non il n'y a rien rien
n'est fait les mecs l'ordinateur
s'emballe un peu la position s ultra
compliqué c'est le genre de truc ou
l'ordi va te battre un gros avantage
mais sait on en parlait en fait c'est
moins clair que des fois des trucs à + 0
80 c'est moins clair que ding mvl où il
y avait juste ce plus 0,9 et avec avec
mathieu on est en sueur parce qu'il n'ya
pas un plan pour les noirs ou même
topalov maxime dans la première ronde
ok c'est un avantage là c'est plus de 30
mais en fait je fais une erreur c'est
moins mais qu'il ya du temps ils ont
encore plus de 10 minutes chacun donc
c'est pas encore ça y est nous tous il
ya des grosses gaffes mais pour
l'instant on rit qui n'a bien joué
bastien le médecin que f
ok c'est pas invisible mais c'est bien
pour le mans grosse partie du joueur
russe mais le joueur français kiki
encore qui encore dans la game fab façon
maxime c'est un bon défenseur et de
calcul mais là il a pris des mauvaises
décisions avant elle a en fait il a pas
le choix de vraiment trouver le français
le français allait à l'efap c'est aussi
là dessus que sajoo c'est sur le fait
d'être français attaque du jour france
aux français attaque attaque de thibaut
pinot il est parti seul
il ne sera plus repris fab le coureur
colombien bernal ne peut pas suivre et
le français qui s'envole dans l'alpe
d'huez dans la roue de richie porte quoi
adverse à reprendre en juillet le tour
de france est fantastique j'attends ça
avec impatience votre voix qui est
d'autant transparent couet alors moi je
regarde vraiment que pour les étapes de
montagne avec les commentateurs si on
est bons fous attaque
en fait ce qu'aiment les mieux les
étapes de montagne c'est la playlist
passe rien tu as dit gabon il faut dépit
des échappés sont reprendre c'est un
sprint qui règne tout va cela chez le
maillot jaune dans un très mauvais jour
nous le peloton roule avec un vent trois
quarts favorables
ne courez pas à côté des coureurs
n'auraient pas à côté des coureurs comme
à droite il le dit ouais c'est vrai que
je veux tu qu'on leur répéter ce que
j'ai à chaque année entre les mêmes
trucs là et ça sent l'été comme c'est ça
la bonne fin de l'année séparés c'est
une tradition très française car validé
quatre joué par le joueur français
alors bon temps france 5 c'est le bon
coup ce qu' il peut plus se planter
faire du c3 par exemple est mauvaise et
roissy la merde ça aurait dit à quel
point m
5 ça se voit très vite en fait cela
revient sur france 5 mhz et échanger
damage quatre échecs et van damme h4 bof
bof mais bon ok si ça te fait enfermer
ton qui a validé les projets d'autres
non mais c'est pas où vous mettez pas
mates non non je sais ils permettent à
tous les coups sont positifs ou quatre
intermédiaires aussi pourquoi pas
peut-être que c'est le genre de cookies
jeu mais bon faut 4 faut comprendre que
c'est si l'un comptant non mais j'ai dit
ça sans regarder leur vie en fait je
vois votre fouquereau qu'il prend de 9,3
j'imagine pourquoi je vois me l'échanger
à mais tu mens pas 300 x 4 h un échec
améliorée
il y aura des matches 4 ok on ces
bandits je suis rien de vrai de pointe
dès que les blancs ils ont pas vraiment
de coup très mauvaise ils ont été très
bon challenge à m6 la fouge et 4 ce que
lecavalier protège la tour mais pas tout
de suite
non mais tu t'approches 5 c'est logique
c'est malencontreux et tanger vitrine
manchester est ok d'un des deux autres
est-ce que c'est quoi le fameux droit
d'être fin faut prendre cinq îles qui
est d'habitude on a quoi tu es sur ces 3
c il a touché 4 donc l'idée de dan d2
c'est que quand tu fais tout reprend
tour gildan des deux tu t'en lève aussi
des maisons encore et adam eve deux
attaques et 5 9 6 non mais c'est dur
c'est je sais pas mais qu'il est fou
drogue non mais une fois que tu l'as vu
ses ultras logique
ouais mais le problème c'est que mes
vont très compliqué très compliqué dont
je n'y peux y peut trouver mais très
rentable non mais j'ai envie de dire tu
peux trouver au hasard au hasard c'est
juste ça fait partie des coûts candidat
tu peux trouver sans comprendre que ce
soit si forme juste c'est le premier
truc que tu as regardé il se trouve que
c'est bien parti
non mais tu empruntes 5 se privent que
tu regardes quoi
oui mais attends je vais vite faut
penser à dam des deux sinon tu élimines
nettoya plutôt prince et donc je regarde
ces 3 ou show au théâtre alors on va
jeter un oeil à l'autre partie fab eu un
dépôt qui est en train de solidité est
il ce n'est pas trop mal à la pendule
s'échauffent à l écoute on va voir ce
que jouant de keane
donc bon alors là les mecs ont commenté
un petit peu avec lord histoire de
pouvoir suivre parce que quand on sait
que vous regardez tous avec stockfisch
on veut essayer d'être sanand rapide
sinon vais raconter que de la merde
sinon tu peut longer non mais on se
remet de son temps en temps des ventes
de chevaux de calcul m
c'est pas mal de la voir quand même
femme je pense ici aux rapides parce que
on en met là on peut l'enlever
maintenant qu'on a vu détails maintenant
qu'on peut un peu l'envers histoire
revient et ça marche aussi très chaud et
vous mais là c'est non mais ho guen sait
que l'ordi ci jouent tous les coups
tordus oui c'est grave mais c'est très
dur de tous par là c'est vraiment très
compliqué on va voir bat maxime a bien
raté le h4 qui était génial pour les
noirs qui paraissait très logique
j'ai du mal à capter leur renfort pas
c'était fort polian mais pour quelle
raison il a pas fait je me dont way
andré kinkela passe super bien joué
aussi d'après lors des cavaliers c3
thaler et touffah renoncer c'est mais en
fait ils ont deux pas oui parce que tu
as 400 coups candidat et il a fait fou
et 3 tu vois comme quoi qui est pas bon
maintenant qu'ils n'étaient pas vendeurs
qui était pas bon du tout choqué voire
du tout je sais pas mais qui passe 107
rouge alors maxime va sûrement prendre
f5 noah lecavalier
ah bon mais ok c'est un côté logique
faut trop affectueux grand roque assez
vite si tu peux donc à faire cavaler
prend genre un truc comme tourcoing
5 je pense je pense mais bon t'as des
couilles 30 rock & roll un pion de plus
belle cavalli ouais tu fais le tour je
suis peut-être en premier
nominé cet ouvrage dahmane s'en prend
aux mêmes sinon tu prends d'hommes
crans-montana matches quatre sites en
langue
ok mais en fait même ça c'est pas si
simple
tu peux faire dame prend avec les blancs
que les prend et grands et aux quêtes
avions plus mais joint l'onu oui bon
choix
enfin je dis je non mais là je déjà je
pense pas que les blancs vont gagner
mais pour que les morgans quand même une
certaine période
une autre paire de manches mais je pense
c'est une très bonne nouvelle à battre
son faux 3e de poule 4 où le veau jintao
frangins et forcément ça donne ni te
donne un truc un peu près égal mais bon
enfin ça reste chaud ça à chaud je
préfère avoir les blancs ici mes moyens
il ya 3,5 par l'adam d2 on a remis le
redis pour voir ma tête de série numéro
un et c'est alors il veut prendre des
quatre maisons bizarre enfin t'as pas
une pièce piétons fou non mais tout voir
et je sais pas des handicaps il touré
fin mai mais qui mais je vous comprends
tout du coup se faire complice ça c'est
logique tout ça mais bon mais genre non
mais je comprendrais puces d'amd de
fougères et quatre petits rock à la
région emea qu'avait lieu de et d'un
match quatre matches c'est pour ça que
ça marche pas m meiway question les
projets quatre noms à la kf3 non
ouais donc dan des deux fous j'ai quatre
tours f1 ouais c'est logique tevita truc
en f3 non ça c'est choquant mais ok tout
est possible que j'aie vraiment mais je
dois dire en fait peut-être nv le favori
dans ce genre de combat de rue toujours
pour la bonne raison que c'est plus son
style de partie mais en tout cas pour
l'instant personne et ultra précis donc
il y aura sûrement d'autres terrains à
venir et j'ai pas de quelques ça va
tomber
non après dans une telle position c'est
normal que les joueurs ne soient pas
apprécié non mais tu peux juste précis
surtout trouve la bonne ligne sous le
joug et oui oui mais je leur parle assez
il ya une question de réussite dans ce
genre de partie j'ai envie de dire
mesdames des deux fous j'ai quatre
appareils ultra logique allait peut-être
damev de i see you ouais mais plus dur
parce que tu veux tu as trois des deux
noms mais touré fin c'est long d'être
convoqué six paris mesdames on joue
contre ma part il faut prendre des
quatre rouges et quatre intermédiaires
bond hommes de hockey et apoel froid
aussi
il a prié fouet f3 en feu
après ces coiffes au projet qu'il a
trahie et des dames à cinq échecs et
dames 3 et 5
il a raté sa chaussure qu'est-ce qu'il a
raté balle à la partie du narrateur ils
croient qu'ils avaient faux proche des 4
il a pas ici à damas cinq à chaque arrêt
donc maxime qui a un coût de répit oui
mais c'est très grave tout gens plus
conne rires eh oui mais je sais très
bonne nouvelle
il a raté la tactique de maximilien jeu
frangié kata d'amitié c'est 3 et à me
prendre cinq autres épreuves 3 pour la
fin du monde mais ben ali n'a ressemblé
pintadeau donc jusqu'à au pire tu en
auras q1
du coup il a dû penser sur france 3
c'était fou price renforcer widom
prendre tu content d'apprendre à 5 avec
lé petit et grand roque qui est
l'ordonnancé sur bon je pense que ça a
tourné la finlande très clairement
complètement maxime peut la gagner c'est
là du coup je pense balawi faso well as
i les délais de bonnes choses rien ouais
donc la tient que parce que tu adoption
plus parce que petit coup sur la tête
pour nike inc qui joue à fond pour
gagner la comprends que en fait je dois
je suis de faire nul maintenant et c'est
plus dynamique
ouais non là je la sens bien pour maxime
et il lui manque un coup quoi
alors vrai qu'il est ce qui peut faire
un dames 2 août à tamines trano d'amazon
d'une prothèse qu'il en soit il va
peut-être faire un coup comme c4 ou c3
c3 bons potes là clairement la bonne
nouvelle parce qu'après c'est trop en
fait tu en train d'ouvrir un peu à
droite à gauche trois ne va pas être en
sécurité avec les blancs mais la crise
est qu'à espérer que d'autres états de
tout ça se passerait bien là pour le
joueur français fab donc là là ça va
faux faucilles et de 2,2 de conclure en
photo ouais là il peut il peut gagner
maxime c'est vraiment le genre de parti
qu'il affectionne
je suis en se faisant passer c'est
normal plus tour un peu tout ça laurent
blanc il sera jamais à l'abri qui aura
pour mission n'est pas l'abri gbagbo
alors nous aussi donc il reste au centre
un peu commun comme un jambon est énorme
d'autant que le pinceau comme le
rappelait le seul problème c'est de
cavaliers des 5
il est fort il est fort non mais c'est
pas encore gagné mais
déjà on pense plus à perdre c'est déjà
bien c'est quelque chose quoi bon après
tout peut encore arriver
ouais mais ok voilà nom de défaite ça
restons quand même fab méfiant valider
des blancs ckoi pas trop de mon pote si
adam g 5 quand même ses cavaliers c7
c'est ça ouais bah oui et encore oui
mais oui bon là oui c'est un problème
parce que tu vas faire juste d'un
métronome eux deux et encore même là
mais bon non mais bon au mieux on fait
permettre donc logiquement en plein mais
présente l'absence et la bon je suis pas
violent mais si on regarde notre cave à
l'effort et damas cinq ans on va y
perdre à me prends des cinq comme menace
on prépare de grands rock quoi faire
mieux c'est fantastique c'est dur pour
les blancs juste c'est sûr maxime qui a
pris de jeu ça sent très très bon fab
est fou pranger quatre intermédiaires
prison des deux dames échec roi là mais
le problème c'est qu'il ya deux pièces
attaqué pour les blancs donc ça tient
aussi bon écoute comme ça elle
appartient il peut tenter franges et
quatre intermédiaires parce que ce rêve
des français ça semble ça semble se
diriger vers une position très difficile
pour le joueur russe
là mon club donc il a pris en c3 qui a
laissé passer sa chance
il ay là il a eu sa chance le joueur
russe mais dans le genre partie
compliquée en fait oui oui
bhatti était vraiment inspiré plus gagné
dure 20 mai mais sont trouvables wayne
ans et est trouvable sais pas il n'y a
pas vraiment de coordinateur ask de
folie juste qu'ils la passent assez
logique mais il a raté que vous arrange
et 4 dames à 5
qui est des cinq erreurs mais tellement
facile à rater bien sûr c'est quand même
dur mais juste
voilà qu elles se dirigent et qui est
quand même sous une bonne étoile pour
pour ces grands prix contre topaloff
il ya eu un peu la réussite là aussi
alors évidemment il a il va la chercher
la réussite mais si l'adversaire
trouvent les coups il perd à chaque fois
donc ouais mais c'est un peu dans chaque
parti comme ça en photo oui mais bon je
veux dire par là que ça peut m'aider
situation où ça peut mal tourner ok la
fed ben bernanke dont j'avais vu dans le
shanxi par les qualifs 6 en fait pas
grave hein juste onze jours 7 / kg 4 ans
et le trou devrait on nous embête c'est
voilà ce qu il te reprend ensuite orange
suite c'est laurent blanc qui en danger
parce que dame français 3 arrive
tourache un peu tatouage 2 je sais pas
un cahier g5 qui revient les vias noir
convergent est ok mais c'est bon coup
franc j'avais vu lors des 10es ça qui du
coup non mais du coup c'est pas si notre
engagement de faire le coup camp adverse
et dame prend 2 5% se poser mais on les
avoirs que le plus dans cette finale et
ça c'est pas gagné
qui a aidé huit tours ces sept on
attaque la coste histoire tourbe évite
un 8e tour à chiens pour l'heure nos
meubles bon mais ça il va voir non c'est
d'avoir un très bon c'est quand même
bien paul martin non plus mais tu es
passif le fou les formes et yahsat
applause diriger dans la nuit vers la
ville et non et si andry qui n'ont ils à
se remettre et à sauver sa le match
restera très très chaud mais en tout cas
je garde espoir pour que maxime puisque
pas très grand mais c'est une option
cet échec
oui mais du coup tu as joué autour des
800 la position et les bons de réduction
ses patrons coup tu regardes en fait non
ok alors dit dans nos quatre très fort
mais oui en fait non mais c'est hyper
tient chaud 4 non ça c'est il y à sa
saga mais non c'est chaud mais il peut
trouver ni peu trop vite ou trop
encore une fois le 4c trouvable mais ok
you're exception prend à regarder
ouais mais tu vois ton casier du commun
donc sauf n'importe quoi et cela alors
il va débarquer et s'appuyant sur dieu
il a fait cas et g5 ces partis des trucs
du rock est fou prend obligé sans frais
tout chaud et froid attaquait dams est
obligé de me prends des trucs objets
alors là tu attaques h1 il tâta qu'à
moitié g4 qui est à mach 4 est logique
je sais pas deux ans de ouais bah oui
parce que s'ils bougent là tu vas
pouvoir mais c'est logique s'il vient
sur la colonne f tu pourras faire des
détours f1 ont des trucs d'homme d'état
qui arrivent donc je serai ta dam des
sept qui arrive donc du ku'damm c6
logique bouffier 6 bouffe ces 6es du
prochain mercato gamme une finale à
défendre mais ça peut gagner ça fasse
gagner
c'est très bien de gagner du coup la
radiation vais prendre commencer par
tour là là encore une fois que tu la
mets ça sur h théâtre tu es fou 17
français son mari c'est très logique
tomber cette mais bon écoute je sais pas
ok là fait qu un magnet ces chèques
intermédiaire wife 7 est maintenant
l'ordi donne moins 300 gagnait 6,92
gagne moins 3 maxime a joué thème pour m
et je peux comprendre via le pion c'est
rend l'air rien c'est fini bah écoute
ses buts c'est une super nouvelle non
pas du goût seront six qualifiés ils
veulent pas perdre écrit mon prénom nom
là du coup bah ça me semble gagner je
vois pas hénaff et rock et h3 échec
ok mais bon on va quand même attendre sa
suite à ces sermons et des
rebondissements dans la partie
clairement ça sent très bon lequel de
revenir sur f4 en plus il veut venir
bloquer cette colonne f
c'est quelque chose et on a de plus en
plus avec le nord ça sent très bon mais
après une nouvelle fois c'est pas les
positions 100%
non mais ça va pas c est les bons peut
même pas d'attaqué non non ça va aller
tu as beau avoir un rôle si ce qui monte
dans l'espace bon il est tranquille fait
son cosmonautes très très safe
non mais surtout qu'est en plus maxime
joue très très vite peut-être 45 contre
une seconde ouais ouais ouais c'était
chose de partir mais ça tombe bien il a
bien fait leurs preuves 6 ouais bon ça
c'était sûr partie incroyable un party
wii party parti cheveux de chaud les
marrons qu il est bon en un clic un
maxime incroyable il s'en est tellement
bien sorti de gauche à droite et c'est
ça et c'est la variante et maintenant
c'est le roi blanc qui est mal entré
dans qui aura pas pu tenir le niveau
tactique du joueur français
tout bêtement
bon maintenant il doit bouger le footsie
engrangé 4 ces deux menaces et après tu
vois ça tu prends ces trois qui aura
même des tours / g et c'est fou quand
même finir le boulot
mais même en jouant pas très près ce qui
juste une question style avec les noirs
et adoptons plus il va devenir henry va
venir en f3 mais auquel je faisais des
français 3 déjà sont possibles des torts
g8 ce que tu veux tous les coups sont
bons
quelle grosse partie du joueur français
quand même fab il aura sorti une grosse
grosse partir sais pas quel point ce qu
on avait des problèmes mais en tout cas
la plus présent grande fallait trouver
les coûts là le s'éprend des dames à 5
des trucs comme ça ça oui à l'avant
c'est jamais très propre ces bas vont
m'aider à moins de quoi oui mais c'est
pour ça qu'il ya des mâts du mal contre
comme compte des joueurs comme
comme caruana ou comme dingli rennes et
ou qui sont hyper précis et qui
réussissent à à faire le boulot jusqu'au
bout mais à mai contre des joueurs un
peu moins que tu demandes qui ont un
effort de fou quoi c'est de rester à un
niveau très haut tout le long des côtes
belges
vous les voyez à l'oeil ou alors dit non
à les voir alors dit non non non mais
serait alors tu vois que c'est dangereux
mais tu sais pas à quel point ce que
veut dire frappe c'est que s'est pas
départi housse est menée de main de
maître de a à z etc ça gagne entre
guillemets sur un jeu parfait c'est que
là il laisse entre guillemets des petit
badge par les deux tiers des balles de
match mais des balles de jeu à
l'adversaire et après si l'adversaire
les convertis qui trouve les coups bas
maxime n'a pas vraiment son destin entre
les mains à 100 % mais mais il mise sur
le fait que ses adversaires seront pas
capables de tout trouvé et c'est bon je
dois donc là andré kim qui tente un
petit contre jeu avec damas ces témoins
il voit en dessous de complot défendre
les cases pourrait fuiter
ça va aller juste bon vieux rock alors
tu fermes ta d'amendé vite en fait j'ai
recensé assez solide mais juge chalon va
le faire c'était juste un truc comme ça
ma maison d'ahmed 7,3 g 520 contre
toutes les cases noires la série
d'objets soit on continue de s'en aller
où on fait qu'il gît 6 ou je sais pas
quoi
moi je comprends h 4 min mais non non ça
tient en fait ok juste se dire c'est que
c'est très réconfortant de voir un coup
comme des huit que j'aime on va jouer
celui déjà l'argent aucun souci pour nom
mais on va aux maximes vacant de valider
je sais pas s'il viendra un autre je
sais pas quoi le joie pas comment mon
nom mais il est vraiment il est vraiment
un niveau au dessus
saint véran penser c'est comme quand tu
qu'on des joueurs vraiment moins fort
que toi ô de chaque genre 200 300 points
de moins et que tu sens que dans tous
les cas tu vas réussir à la faire
tourner en sa faveur c'est vraiment
l'impression que ça donne c'est qu'il
est vraiment il est vraiment
cibox une catégorie au dessus quoi des
joueurs de ce niveau là c'est un poids
lourd ouais t'as vraiment l'impression
qu'il est large il est très large il est
très large
tu as mis à part gris tchouk aronian tu
vas aller les sept huit noms qu'on
connaît j'ai l'impression contre les
autres joueurs
son style est juste ouais mais c'est
beau parce qu'en fait c'est juste un
sens un style pas tellement contrôler
mais c'est beaucoup plus en contrôle que
né poma mais ouais bah de maxime il va
toujours très loin dans ce tournoi
il s'est pas planté par par des macabres
oui c'est exactement ce que je voulais
dire mais en revanche j'ai l'impression
qu'on des mecs comme dingoo caruana ça
montre un peu ses limites
ouais bon ok c'est déjà dans le top 5
mondial construit oui mais c'est bien le
truc c'est marrant parce que j'ai
l'impression que contre les faibles
c'est plus en contrôle parce que toute
façon tu les fenêtres au monde derrière
un calcul ou je ne sais pas et il a fait
dahmane 10 damas où j'ai mal je crois
que tout gagné ne fait quoi que toi je
trouve la fedama 6 mai
ce fort d'un associé ou non me va très
bien pu rentrer en d3 tadam tu vas tu
fais tout et tu vas peut-être aussi
menacé même des tours bref trois jours
avec ça en l'air c4est là maintenant la
cage g8 et plus contrôlée et va voir les
tours h trois tours g8 ou rage 2 et
compagnie tout la bonne compagnie et au
québec coûte on se dirige donc vers une
belle victoire
une partie quand même à rebondissements
qui était chaude au moins on a vibré et
je pense ça va reprendre dans pas trop
longtemps après alors à temps et encore
oui car yakine qui joue ouais mais alors
oui mais non mais on finit maximum oui
oui mais du verre par là ça va jouer
jusqu'au bout ça va pas reprendre tout
de suite puisqu'il ya eu qui joue web
ont peu ou pas les surprenne fois que
c'est fini mais ça ne devrait pas tarder
pour finir chez maxim je pense il va
nous faire du tutorat je crois je pense
que le sens je pense qu'avoir une une
flambée de cas les parcelles
avec une victoire du français qui semble
inéluctable maintenant voilà c'est la
variante que je voulais te dénoncer afab
ce qu'il faut pour entreprendre les
trois donc romain doit être jouée mais
du coup on se faire taper à deux aussi
et le roi blanc et en place au mieux
attaquer de tous les fronts par toutes
les pièces mais le truc c'est que
maintenant
non il déboulera 1,6 comme très
tranquille tu risques il ya tout qui
rende à damas 2002 son arme est là
depuis 6 c'est un peu un ice king
mais bon il va pas complètement feront
que des pans de 3 à 5 en premier
attendez la dame b 4 qui a aidé trois
faut faire gaffe et encore ça en l'air à
la fin ouais mais ça va rôder pour un
jour ça va rôder à je suis 3-2 en fait
chez blanc peuvent plus rien faire saas
et cloud et saas et ce n'est pas close
sa sévices et à la protection de sa
voiture à dévorante marrant genre ça ça
elle en fait ce qui est drôle c'est que
s'il revend en f1 je suis ton problème
faisant premiers s'ils revendent et tu
peux faire un échec
turfoo revenir et lui taper sa voix
lasse a abandonné c'est gagné on a bien
le jeu fabuleux joueur français est une
grosse partie pour la grosse partie
belle belle partie qui est on est passés
par des hauts des bas
on est passé par toutes les émotions
faut trois déjà fautes faciles à dire 20
somme il faut 3 et la 4 fautes 1 re semi
faute est en tout cas au moins fleuve
trois grosses fautes en d2 puis on prend
et rock peut-être et sa joyeuse pagaille
et 6 tu verser 3 tu veux faire tu rêves
de doublé les tours je sais pas tu as
plein de choses qui peuvent arriver en
mai la personne est mieux c'est juste
très chaud avant l'été c'est toute la
tranche 5 ou je ne sais quoi c'est
tellement un problème finalement
finances et maxime qui s'en est mieux
tiré avec avec les blancs ça devrait
aller on regardera quand même et andré
khimki a pas un répertoire pléthorique
on va juger tu as un oeil sur la partie
de carrière keane puisque j'ai envie de
dire attends que cette partie là n'est
pas fini fab
d autres noms peuvent vous êtes ne
reprendront pas
oui qui a une qualité d'avant ce qui
devrait gagner je devrai gagner se
diriger vers une demi-finale surprise
face à navarra satwa de l'élite mondiale
quoi d'avoir aboli en demies croyable du
coup c'est la qualif cmv elle passe même
s'il n'est pas là non au ciné pop un box
non loin de là ciné pop as il y aura une
demi finale de tous les dangers et qui
feront corde il ne va gagner le grand
prix on signerait on signe on signe
imagine vlad
oui je me remets aux échecs si même lui
peut gagner
donc ce serait bien pour nos vins qui
gagne en photo ce serait bien je pense
ou faire une vidéo troll avec vlad
sinagra gagne genre on analyse avec vlad
la finale quoi attendons assez gagné
puisque sur fo il y avait trois détroit
avec la petite fourchette chez millions
dans c'est cool c'est cool c'est mignon
fab grosse et là on a eu chaud après
peur bruce ce jour on n'a jamais été
correctement foutu non plus quoi non on
n'a pas été foutu mais mais il ya eu la
petite goutte sur le front tu as vu leur
is it has his ou quoi qu'ils pouvaient
non t'as pas eu le petit la petite la
petite frissonna da ouais non mais c'est
quand même plus excitant des partis
comme ça que c'était une fourmi en face
que tu écrases tu n'en auras pas c'était
pas l'écrasent adam et
mais c'était c'était chaud dans c'était
plus sympa c'est plus sympa c'est le
fusain pas bon maintenant avec les
blancs il va falloir assurer le coup
mais elle fait le taff et reste maître
de son dessin est exactement et il a été
bon dans la tête
maxime
il a été solide au moment où il le
fallait non mais là je suis confiant en
revanche si ça continue dans le match
nepos on va quand même suivre des
poteaux jusqu'au bout fab mais pour
savoir ce qu'il en est parce que ça
pourrait être synonyme de qualification
pour maxime rigaud tombe comme ça on
vous dira si les stream continue aux
deux jours en plus quoi ah oui oui bah
oui si maxime est qualifié et sous est
qualifié on va pas continuer à stream
est pour rien enfin la qualification
sera faite fera peut-être des petites
parties s'il ya quelque chose de joli
mais mais ce ne sera pas notre pauvre un
aussi gros studios mais écoute bon voilà
c'est bien parti
écoute c'est cool je pense à reprendre
bientôt
doit-on une mini pause faire un petit
café ou quoi genre un discours prononcé
à 4,49
je pense que si on 17 minutes quand même
d'avoir laissé souffler de seconde ok ok
bon tu as on surveille tout de suite les
mecs je mets une petite pause et je mets
une petite pipe aussi a tout de suite
l'élite bonjour à tous
alors ça y est on change de siècle et
ont fait part d'un nouveau joueur
c'est alexandre à les kin donc joueurs
nés en russie
les quines donc est né vers moscou à
moscou en 1892
et donc a passé sa jeunesse il a appris
les deux chats que l'âge de 7 ans et
puis jouer un peu avec son frère le
terrain il a pas mal de jeu par
correspondance puis il a lancé sa
carrière petit à petit mais c'est vite
la lra sèment assez talentueux quoi et
donc dans les premières vidéos sur ali
keane
beh compte un peu montré les partie de
sa jeunesse comme pas encore le rongeur
qui va devenir mais comment il est monté
en puissance et c est donc à noter voilà
donc les quines et russes mais qu'il a
demandé la nationalité française plus
tard il est devenu français en 1927
même s'il vivait depuis un petit moment
je crois qu'il est parti de russie
d'après ce que j'ai lu vers 1921 il ya
des problèmes un peu je crois le régime
communiste et donc il a préféré fuir il
a été deux fois arrêté là fait de faire
faire tuer fallu plus d'une histoire sa
rocambolesque en fait aussi une fois en
1914 puis je vois le un tournoi à
mannheim en allemagne et après la guerre
mondiale éclate en plein milieu du
tournoi et il s'est fait arrêter la
bande allemagne où les mythes accusé
justement d'être un agent double russes
qu'ils espionnaient la enfin il ya ces
mouvementée mais finalement il s'en est
sorti puis l'a fait pu faire sa carrière
donc deux joueurs d'échecs
voilà avec de si tous ces détails
historiques vous intéresse vous tremblez
notés en dessous et puis vers sera de
faire un détail un exposé un peu plus
détaillée a juste fait en gros mais donc
voilà est donc la première partie qu'on
va regarder ses parts et les kin en 1907
donc il ya d'autres parties de lui avant
disponible mais surtout par
correspondance et donc je préfère
prendre une partie de tournoi normale
entre guillemets parce d'échec voilà
donc j'ai en 1907 ou van der sar qui
s'appelle isakov constantin et
et puis on va voir ça don kelly qui
n'allait blanc et la jouer car ok donc
le 4 4 premiers cours son adversaire
cinq cavaliers pts 3 kelly c6 et il sait
ça il ya une ouverture en génie ces
trois donc ces trois pas très vu comme
coup quelque part mais apparence assez
logique en fait on a un pion pour
contrôler des quatre et on veut jouer à
nous mêmes des quatre ensuite décrit un
gros centre de pions alors le défaut
c'est quoi bon valoir dans la partie
c'est soit que les noirs ajouté cinq
comme ils l'ont fait et dont vous êtes à
kindia devant le centre blanc parce que
le truc c'est qu'après puis on prend
dame prend ben on n'a pas en plus de
provoquer ces trois axes très pénible
qu'on a occupé la caisse par un pion il
ya une autre possibilité pendant et des
5 s'est fait recaler m6 est directement
dans que l'attaqué soupe sion sur
leucate et là les blancs soit ils
feraient des trois pour le défendre
les frais quand même des quatre pour
contre attaquer ou 5 mais c'est une
autre variante alors toujours est il les
dents on fait des cinq qui a un très bon
coup allez qui n'a joué badama quatre
dames à 4 pas malheur c'est l'idée de
ventes ces deux de cloud cavaliers en c6
pour pouvoir prendre l'option de 5
ok epci ceux des champions très bien ce
bon tu réponds encore foulé 5 on en
remet une couche sur lequel il sait si
ce qui à mes yeux cette ok tout défendu
si on prend dé 5,2 me prendrait 5 les
blancs rock et reggae marie la jouer le
petit coucou 17 très bien on coûte
développement et puis enlève le clouage
sur le calice et six mois a écrit blanc
lait qui n'a joué des 4 et son
adversaire donc isakov a joué le coup
eux quatre quais par anvers qui est pas
mauvais mais peut-être que à 6 c'est
encore mieux
et d'ailleurs asthénique à six vitesses
jouée par parra liqin lui-même donc par
correspondance en 1902 donc à l'époque
il avait juste dix ans et donc pas mal
assise soit donc l'idée basse et sa
nasse d'un premier 5
l'adversaire a dit qu'il avait retiré
son fond ces quatre cas c'est une faute
parce qu'il avait tiré les prend petit
combine attaque la dame à 4 et donc sur
fou prend ici on retire le cavaliere
deux échecs comme ça sera plus en l'air
brault h1 et fo prend 1,4 et les noirs
sont clairement du bon il a quand même
perdu la partie en liquide mais comme je
lisais les dix ans donc ça peut aussi se
comprendre mais bon la laideur sont
beaucoup mieux
clairement clairement ouais non sur a6
normalement il faut jouer 6 4 il faut
jouer 6 4 avec les blancs et d'amd ci
semble possible mais d'un 27 pas mal
aussi
l'idée c'est que sur des cinq et un coup
bizarre qui tient le tient la baraque
c'est tour à sept alors ça cesse pour
ceux d'entre vous qui veulent vraiment
ou si la théorie et idées etc si les
blancs en caisse la pièce ici on reprend
du pian le fou a pas trop de casse de
suite font pas du tout
et quand il prend ainsi son peu le
pourchasser comme ça c'est 8 on va alors
gagné donc l'un dans l'autre on aura une
égalité matérielle mais la paire de chou
et donc quand on reprend à six sont à
gagner attention la dame on va enlever
ce cavalier
on va sortir le fougeux par le set en d6
quelque part faire petit rock et jouets
pour un avantage plutôt long terme avec
les voiles à la fois c'était le petit
côté théorique mais me voilà qu'elle
pouvait par exemple 4 ça va mais là si
spaemann et puis on voit donc là avec le
c4 qui prendrait quatre que déjà très
jeune il a une bonne vision tactique
quoi les quines et ça a été un une de
ses grandes caractéristiques en fait il
est il a encore retenu dans l'histoire
qu'on est très très bon joueur d'attac
mais il a fait évoluer les choses ne
s'étaient pas joints d'attac qui se
jetaient à tout va un peu comme dans
l'est
les romantiques ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
présent en fait dans vos vidéos c'était
plus construit comme jeu stérile attaqué
s'il avait le terrain pour c'était un
des premiers joueurs vraiment complet en
fait aux échecs et et voilà bon bref les
normes et voilà les noms je veux quatre
balles et retiré le cavalier et fringues
bien jouer normal partie fixe entre qui
a eu les baies 3 directions c5 ici et là
petit coussin pages autant les noirs
cavaliers aux 5
donc il est bien sûr section prend il
vous prend b5 et s'il faut prendre 17
alors alors les noirs ferait cavalli
prend laisseraient pas leurs cavaliers
en mer à des quinas gens qui haïssent et
5 mai il faut prendre cette route est
bien sûr possible aussi et de superbes
sûrement une petite faute quand même de
la part des baignoires qui ont fait ces
six donc la première vue s'appelle ayo
mais savez là peut-être mieux fait juste
d'échangés et puis d'enlever ce cavalier
emprise le ramener la part courir à
l'échec et bomba le truc en fait on est
de retour femmes
on n'a pas laissé la vidange jusqu'au
bout parce que ma priorité au direct
mais les gens peuvent la retrouver sur
sur youtube exactement donc ben belle
victoire fab
alors on a un petit choses importantes
comme on a lu dans le chat que vous
disiez que en cas de qualification de
sow s'était pas encore fait on a vérifié
avec fabre pendant la pause on avait
déjà dit hier et avant-hier c'est bel et
bien fini
si maxime se qualifier que sauce
qualifie simple calcul c'est que si
maxime se qualifie pour pour la demie il
va marquer minium trois points on va
dire qu'il en restera là et leur à 3
points donc il avait 13 points avant le
début du tournoi selon fra 16 13 + 3 et
sohar entendant avait quatre points donc
la victoire
la victoire finale
ces huit points si tu marques bonus à
chaque tour ses douze bon il trouve que
dans ce match là il aura pas de bonus
c'est une moderne
bah ouais c'est une mode r oui la petite
variante way et ouais donc ce au maximum
marqué 11 points et qu'améliorer avec 4
ça fait 15 et 15 est inférieure à 16
voilà pour la petite info qui a quand
même son importance fab
oui bah c'est qu'en gros louis xi mac se
qualifie et que sow se qualifie c'est
fini on vote oui c'est la bonne nouvelle
pour les avants stream mais bon nous on
a envie en fait que des pots et d'avoir
une belle demi et puis voilà quoi ouais
on veut qu'ils se gagne on voudrait
qu'ils gagnent
en montrant vraiment qui est le patron
absolu du gagne surtout qu'il en a les
capacités
après je te cache pas que d'histoires de
son on prend aussi un bain du kung fu de
choses de notre semaine après wifi bon
on sera content et puis on pourra
préparer les candidats et l'équipe pour
commenter et c'est en toute tranquillité
sérénité alors il fait quoi est fait
qu'est c3 c6 cave à la fraude des six à
quatre rouges et quatre fois de dessin
gaffes et des cinq en deux temps mais me
denis de l'annonceur
oui et je vais mettre du goût de l'autre
côté aussi tu sais je veux voir le saut
le saut niveau ce1 espagnols sont ces
bagnoles anti marche à l'extérieur on va
pas se perdre là-dessus
ok moi chez max a lâché max
bon je pense qu'il veut mais c'est pas
genre une vente qui existe mais il y en
a une autre sanction à 4 exactement la
même position
ok + ou - sauf quand j'ai avec les
ventes flash trois mois qui faisait 4
donc en fait andreï keynes qui va faire
ce jeune 28 à filer un tempo et il va te
dire oui bon ok je m'en fiche un peu
dans ce genre de position ce qui sur un
veau s'est pas complètement faux sur mon
toit peut être un truc de génie nommé
mais au moins ça mais une position ça
peut jouer donc avec les blancs fête
soit tu joues avec eux cinq que si on
fermait soit tu essaies d'en échanger au
centre terrain comme fou trop serait
déjà paillaugue un oui à temps la
question s'est prise prises et des six
déjà qui arrivent et e
en fait c'est bien de jouer comme ça
parce que t'as pas partie d'un pion
c'est ce moment-là venir je vais me
tourner autour des vies c'est déjà très
fort non c'est bien je maxime du coup je
pense que il est déjà en crise un
trikini d'espérer bluffé en fait ouais
mais après c'est compliqué de jouer mais
n'est pas commencée avec les blancs tu
dis oui j'ai eu besoin de la nulle je
veux pas donner un pion et c'est là
qu'ils tenaient à peu serré et pas jouer
les coupes du frais en temps normal et
que tu peux perdre et donc bien joué et
montré et continue à fait cai epci
sûrement 1,5 à venir et qui a volé ou 4
un truc comme ça j'imagine c'est encore
meilleurs catcheurs sauf si fort je suis
super confiant bon film appartient qu
bas pas plus pas moins cher je vois pas
maxime perdre avec les gens mais en tout
cas le choix nombril kiné et à soullans
peyo oui ils essayent de garder de
gagner des places en jeu et maxime tu
auras gagné tellement de partir avec les
noirs danseurs mais on sait que le prix
ne viennent plus de voir ses écrits nord
qui accule en général en fait oui mais
c'est impressionnant quand tu refais les
scénarios de match il a battu deux fois
topalov avec les noirs il a battu grille
tout qu'avec les noirs
non mais c'est juste y contre en fait
ils contrent tellement mais ce qui fait
dans plein de temps faute c'est pas
justice m
oui oui mais c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment impressionnant ce ratio de gars
avec les noirs jeu je pense que c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde avec les noirs
en réalité peut-être je serai carole
scène peut-être mais celui qui met le
plus de points pour carl sagan aussi
beaucoup mieux avec sa hache nikov non
mais le truc c'est que ça aussi un
pendant c'est que des foyers des
défaites sur des greens fun
tu me contre mam est con carne scène
les anglaises des petits trucs je sais
pas en fait face et jean saint vaast
aujourd'hui à dire pour moi c'est le
meilleur joueur du wac ça mais ok il dit
juste très dur à jouer tout cas il est
impressionnant le joueur français est
donc un relief 17 ben écoute voulu
garder les pièces sur l'échiquier andré
qui n'est tenté tenté d'envoyer du pâté
allait droit peut-être plus tard ou
d'ouvrir le centre
non mais en fait il veut dire une forme
de structure française lâche cas au
cannet puis j'ai pas faire une partie
long terme en fait vous tu vas être mal
avec les noirs mais essayez de l'oedt
avoir à l'usure ou stratégiques
mais bon le cahier des stades déjà c'est
pas une bonne pièce ne sait pas trop ce
qui va devenir bon bonne chose pour lui
de repasser le fond j'ai cassé dans les
blancs aura sûrement le six attaques de
nuit là bon moi tu es fou prend ça me
laisse assez tard mais c'est plus une
attaque de nuit ces attaques de jours
ouais ben ali l'a vu mais haouet être en
fait un break in the rock et faire ici
suu kyi avait des filles caillou six des
neuf comme ça je sais pas alors maxime
café kg 5
bah il a provoqué en fait ils te force à
faire aussi sec et noir déjà sinon ciel
et blanc qui le font et ok mais du coup
et non pas un jeu très actif
juste les noirs ce qu'ils ont accompli
c'est georges mène française où il ya
plus de quinze manches mais pas le
mariage de la même ouverture de faire
gaffe avec 19 ski qua non mais en fait
je peux comprendre ça c'est juste
mauvais en fait pour les noirs mais site
en mode swing c'est pas con parce que ça
fait les leurs avant d'attaquer en fait
va prendre h quatre cadets match avait
ainsi sur toi de faire agresser
c'est objectivement pas bon mais bon si
l'on se trompe un peu ça la sita faire
ton contre joël dame ça peut aller aussi
il ya eu une partie en fait comme ça au
grand prix précédent c'était les
départage entre du boeuf et duda où
boudouda avait les blancs la première il
est perdu deuxième il est noir il joue
une moderne un peu c'est tombé comme ça
où il retourne dans une structure
française et booba fait plein droit mais
il a raté la tacc pour gagner et il
s'est planté dans la finale en fait
c'est pas fait ça montre juste pratique
d'accord d'accord
mais par ok t'es juste pas trop bien
qu'aucune mais bon pas foutu on jette un
oeil sur les peaux quand même parce que
c'est important est la position juste
butler quand même semble correct pour
sow qui sort bien l'ouverture donc
plutôt une bonne nouvelle de ce côté-là
aussi bas avec un match qui pourrait qui
pourrait durer entre le joueur russe et
le joueur américain
ça ne peut nous rappeler le fameux duel
entre spassky et bobby fischer allez on
fait ce qu'on peut
donc il a joué c'est ça qui veut faire
cavalier ces six dames b6 peut-être même
jouer grand roque d'ailleurs peut-être
bajard quitte à jouer en me souvins me
pour ce rien tu pues garros en turquie
rock et du jeune homme
non mais en fait stratégiquement si les
blancs font rien c'est bien pour les
morts oui parce que tu as plutôt floue
pour ridge à faire crisser silice tu vas
échangés en d4 le quai 17 tu peux
revenir en b6 c4 a dit casse pot rentre
enfin et juste les blancs pouvaient un
truc concret direct h4 et h5 vois tu
dois y aurait d'ailleurs fait kf4 parce
que d'hommes 3 25.961 problème et a pas
de damages 6 non bon non plus à
décaisser satin la bon il ya tout
je pense à damas est sinon un bon kenbé
3 serait que c'est un coup bas 6 à 5
j'imagine un billet déjà qu'il prenait 5
e
oui ça sert avec déjà les histoires ça
peut aller très très vite à côté maxime
les états à -120 qui joue assez vite
assez bien ce qui suit conseils de marc
toesca besoin cette tâche et toi de te
prendre qu ils produisent avec les noms
apparaissent avec sur eux sur ça et et
prend ainsi ses skis et prend une 6 tu
es là c'est un trident la cgc de
nouveaux positon positon qui est de
retour ouais mais ça me paraît déjà dur
pour andré qui peut-être faut faire
petit rock au final 1 oui tu peux les
amphétamines cette madame maîtresse de
très gros projets on vient de voir la
vie bat me trouve des circuits tout je
sais pas quel coup de diaw est non mais
en gros c'est clairement ça en fait tu
peux perdre en vain coûts écrit noir et
à son talent et déjà perdu la première
bombe du comtat chanceux plus ou moins
où les bureaucrates pas de planter les
stratégies quand ça va mais c'est juste
que je dise en fait c'est exactement ce
que tu dirais
est ce qu'on est à la première partie
dans la 2e partie maximale 1 0 dans
maxim qui fait qui fait une bonne partie
pour le moment il a fait cavalier à 3
mai mais du coup du coup c'est pas si
clair première erreur du joueur français
bon nous on avait alors dit on va
peut-être l'enlever mais pour poursuivre
un peu ce début de partie des trois au
caire trois bons la position est
toujours bien pour maxime est juste
c'est pas il n'a pas fini sur le champ
qua non du cavaliere trois dames et
trois forts mais bon il veut fermer
trois mais livré dans chaque dom et 3 se
finissent au second poteau mais si ce
n'est qu'il prend des saintes
québécitude 300 go d'obus de char kiev 8
peut-être mais sûrement de sacrifices
encore qu'ils vont tous monsieur et ça
te tue quand fait peur à l'idée du va
exiger 5 g 4 oui mais couple et ont
peut-être enfin la g55 c'est un souci
mais j'ai 5 g 4 c'est toujours un truc à
regarder dans ces structures parce qu en
fait l'idée c'est de les attaquer le
khalife 3 qui tient défenseurs des
quatre ans donc je rate aucun match 5
peut être candidat ouais mais toi tu
saches 4 à clément tu fixes tout simple
oui oui mais c'est juste pour un
mais oui oui un truc comme ça c'est pas
absurde en général détroit métro ce cas
intéressant et maxime je veux faire x 3
et prend à revers
non parce que ce que je faisais fuite
ok petit rock donc bon x 3 ça va arriver
ils essaient de solidifier le jour avec
bbc soutenu par l'idée nord c'est
vraiment su prend ses seins qui prennent
le 5 quand même ouais il peut jouer deux
fois trois autres sont ce pas mauvais
est-ce que ce que des 6 ou est ce que tu
attends fait du prince et spa times
est ce que tu fais ici avec l'art de
jouer avec a6b 5 peut-être
ouais mais pas trop vite
non mais toi c'est vite certes logique
des gens passionnants alors il faut
varier cavaliers detroit donc maxime qui
vise le pion c5 et il protège quand je
revois la position après rock un
cavalier détroit qui protège 5 et qui
vise c5 et andré qui fêtera ses 8
non même d'un point
surprise c'est sain qui a toujours le
pion aux cinq en l'air pendant qu il
veut arriver à bouger saddam d'un reste
à s'enlever devise aviez cloître il
enlève toutes les pièces vides la
diagonale comme dirait vlad et au kef ou
g5 c'est aussi une autre direction
finalement puisque b3 très peu de faire
x 3 pour autant ouais voilà où 2008
ferait flipper je tiens des cases tu
chapote elle a fait foi à 3
ok et b sides je pense qu'il de faim est
ce qu'on peut dire que tu chaperonne des
cases qui chaperonne dekkers peut-être
ou alors avant l'autre option
éventuellement ces dames et vite
qualifiant ces 5 des français 5 français
5.5 des youtube voiture mange et ça
attention parce que dans cette histoire
c'est 8 arrive ta patrie glace avec les
noirs tu te conseille btc 3 le 5 peut de
fait dans des finales si tu fais g5 et
qui montrent trois marchés soit g6951 ça
c'est typiquement le truc que tu veux
exister ça doit restée nulle mais non
mais c'est l'heure des choix qu'on perd
on va perdre en force ces trompettes
c'est donc peut-être de 8,5 où on va
juste se mettre une petite et val-d'or
dix femmes pour avoir un avis et dames 8
dames 8 md 8c les coûts numéro a et b ci
soit donc là tous les coups qu'on a
mentionné sur les coûts de leurs ordis
29 dans la position qui est revenu vers
zéro et donc andré king qui a survécu
qui a survécu pour le moment l'ouverture
et qui a obtenu ce qu'il cherchait on va
jeter un oeil du côté de dépôt c'est une
partie qui joue particulier très
compliqué mais une époque il ya encore
26 minutes white heat fuite fait du mv
alors soyez kaunas où il veut juste
vivre comme il faut y réfléchir et pas
c'est une salaire dangereux pour lui en
fait la position mais bon vu qu'ils
jouent tous tempo je sais pas de mieux
connaître un boom des vite je vais
perdre et j'ai laissé les mêmes
variantes en quatre présences et 5 tu es
trop faible pour que je réfléchisse
dégage je ne m'intéresse pas ça mais ces
plans de jouer aussi vite ans
non mais ça met une pression en fait ça
m'a vraiment l'impression laser ça non
mais clairement ben est possible ici
même en longues quoi dégage ce jeu de
m'intéresse pas je jouais à dota 2
beaucoup plus intéressant mais il
devrait vous faire à d'autres mais il
est quoi top 10 mondial n'ont aussi ou
100 ans
non il est aux premiers du tout après
certains joueurs comme mauvais voilà
serait 2003 et 2004 2003 2004 où il
n'existe pas en fait c'est un joueur du
bitstream de dota 2 comme une merde
un conte qui fait des sauvageries même
pas en plus on va jusqu'où en fait c'est
pire que toi à bien pire mais bon on a
du coup la partie basse est pas car on
sait juste pas clair et peut-être plus
un genre de truc qui va correspondre
eakin que la partie d'avant
parce que moins tactique on dit pas dota
deux meilleurs sauts de masse et qu'il a
changé de jeu alors qu'avant c'était
dota 2 fait il est passeur sonneurs
sonia plein de joueurs d'échecs qui joue
fab
mais on a 10 ans et qui se loge en tenue
wiering the sun wei a vu leur bonne
humeur par les français mais en fait
j'ai enfin ils ont un niveau légendaire
machin mais enfin ils sont très loin du
top mondial c'est à dire qu'ils sont
forts sans être fort retour à un jouet
on nous dit non mais c'est déjà bien et
bon dans notre jeu brender de sow plein
d'heures de soleil à tourcoing fc est là
oui enfin je sais pas si c'est la baisse
le montant plafond des 50
est-ce que c'est fini trois des cinq tu
te barres tu écris comme en face à un
tel enchaînement en fait le truc c'est
que les vandales rentrée de la demande
de très loin et swan et paul connaît en
fait mais ça tu peux rien y faire
soit si on verra on n'a pas le temps
donc tour à jouer maxime qui conforte le
pion aux 5 et qui va vraiment commencé à
menacer la prison ses cinq ans est ce
qu'on va voir
côté andré quine 1 cd cd d'anne decis
truc comme ça aux fuites un jour même ou
bien sûr j'aurais kiffé fouet fuite
tu perdais prennent sur les cases noir
et blanc peuvent être attaqués avec des
haches 4 h 5 tours troyes coulisser mais
bon c'est clair mais je ferais bien ce
décès des flottilles écoute si si si
j'avais les blancs et que j'étais genre
une partie normale je serais très
mécontent de l'ouverture mais du fait
que la nul face gagné le match je pense
que c'est très convenable comme position
après une autre idée c4 tu fermes pas
tellement en fait couvre ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui ait d'autres éventuels la
case aux quatre ans un problème
je ne sais pas je ne l'aurais pas ça je
fais confiance à un certain fabien libye
z qui il dit ne joue pas je ne joue pas
ces quatre dans la française en lice est
décédé le fou g7 est mince oui mais
pourra revenir en effet investi il
temporise bon logique parce que là pour
le coup en fait les blancs ne sait
vraiment comment ces cinq autant avant
d'accueil preuve d'un grand talent
oratoire en dessous c'est juste une
pièce demain donc en jambes et si si il
y défend son audience et c'est pour ces
huit en gros et préparez vous à voir ce
qu'il veut il sait pas en fait bon ben
là faut faire céder l'avancé 4 ça paie
aucun sens beaucoup ça là pour le coup
là je regarde pas puisque sa ferme le
jeu et du coup faire le jeu tu verras
jamais je donne tu te faire taper allons
faire ça tu peux pas faire alors que
tout à l'heure si tu essaies 4 tu
prouves oeil au moins pour un truc comme
ça
il n'avait pas le temps de faire bkc
avait prise donc il ya une reprise
tu reprends du coup du pion tu es obligé
si tu prends du cavalier il ya eu cinq
en l'air et des coups de balai blanc
près de l'espace mais bon peut-être
fouet fou je suis où je sais pas quoi
sur bay street et à cinq essais 4 mai à
août avec les mains il faut juste
prendre le contrôle de la colonne s'est
plus ou moins non mais ça s'est très
très bien pour avoir du retard il a fait
faux bond à te faire tour c'est cet
incident de s'améliorer sip maman et
noir on prend des décisions ta +50 coûts
pour améliorer avec énorme tas tour ses
sept tours assez vite à l'arrière et
après photo michel bastos schiste parce
qu'avec h6 aprilia à 4 h 5 soit force à
jouer g5
oui mais bon dans grande dame piège 2 kg
4 je suis pas et puis quand elle
5 et 4 à tour valser pas en fait je suis
très confiant non mais on est plutôt pas
mal côté blanc mais bon ne coûte rien et
si je jette un oeil à l'epo il a
toujours pas joué donc ils calculent
forcément tourcoing fc est ce que c'est
quand même le coup tu as envie de
calculer nomme en fait peut-être qu'il
connaissait il sait que c'est pas des
coûts de leurs dix ya un truc que je
trouve et il en est capable
les mauvaises nouvelles ne me rassure
pas dit qu berrigan moi je suis rassurée
sur toutefois absolument que les peaux
bat à messi bat maxime avec le point du
bonus ou quoi ou bien si sera en gagnera
pas ce qui marquera quatre points je
crois annoncé que cinq points c135 n'ont
donc ça va voir qu'il ya une deux
matches dans sa oui bon il peut le faire
aussi comme oui mais bon tour c'est sa
tâche 4 mais je pars est ce que tu fais
je suis senior sur un carnage cg pour
une fête soit je fais rien sauf mais je
ferais plutôt rien en fait l'âge 5 je
ferai pas non mais qu'est ce que je dis
donc je ferais plutôt rien dans ce
domaine de la justice c'est que quand
les blancs de fer h5 qui adore faire
jouer 5 mai oui mais à priori fiat qui
va t'arriver tu es tu te fous rires non
mais tu as raison ce à plus d'expérience
que moi dans notre france il faut juste
rien faire c'est ce qu'il a fait et donc
tour c8 et le joueur russe qui menace
rien non mais il veut échanger en dévier
de ses six sur sept et essayer de
rentrer après l'idée de h5 ça peut être
de ramener le cahier vert f5
ouais mais bon pas rien tout le transit
des cadeaux de faire ouvrir pas
décrocher un truc je trouve et quelle
idée ça tu les fais vraiment rien des
choix tous leurs matchs tombent et 8 ans
il tombe bien plus élaboré et il peut
remplacer les autres en c6 le cas
échéant vous faire pression sur des
cadres maxime qui envoie moi est normal
mais là je ferai ce cahier des baby foot
enfin pas tout de suite ces prend des
quais les babys tous et prend des
cailloux ce qui est dit
et tu aurais pas envie d'essayer de le
faire naviguer vers f8
non mais en fait c'est un tremplin 5e
s'inclinant 7-6 tu poses des quatre
clubs c'est mieux de faire ça si tu peux
le faire en fait si tu te fais maths et
bons trios et après tu essaies kenseth
qui augmentera sur la colonne s'est
tissée devenir un livre 5 loterie
gagnant ces six à toutes tes viassois un
peu quelque chose mais en fait tu veux
presser les cases noires de partout s'il
ya plus de tours tu peux essayer de la
suite d'un assist valence 1 1 pc des
choses mais il faut qu'il trouve d'un
utilitaire des pièces sont donc mais du
coup du coup pendant ce temps maxime
sait très bien ce qu'ils faisaient
4h05 ces normes parti dans le top 7
il a tout vu une photo pas entraîné
s'il vous plaît pas c'est pour jouer
comme ça non mais là il rêve surtout
minutes comme il a pris sa tenue de
réflexion oui mais hier c'est qu'ils
savaient qu'ils avaient quelque chose et
qu'il a fait après c'est pas encore
foutu pour sommer limon bon vas voir
c'est déjà gagné notre match
oui bah ça c'est encore un ferme luxe en
fait alors cariat keynes est mort juste
pour un titre qui a perdu l'aller et le
retour
bauchau pas ce jour ceux ci font du luxe
au bout lymphome alors à moins que il ya
un truc qui soit pas c'est qu'il ya un
problème de de retransmission ce qui est
très peu de coups dans leur parti tout
de même donc c'est prend des quatre
jouer comme tu le comme tu le pense est
envisagé qu'elle prend des quatre ça
paraît bizarre non mais t'as pas vu
parce qu'ils prendront tour ces deux
déjà les noirs est joué et eu forcément
à perdre du temps veulent créer ces 6es
au moins trois tours c'est un oui donc
dans ce sens toi c'est logique
on va voir fab la tension est à son
comble fab et y fait car ils commencent
par caissettes mais on a bien compris
l'idée un jour tu nous la délation
ferais tu nous la montrer tous là
souligné comme d'ab fab tous les coups
du tennis en plus lassés des positions
on a en fait il veut faire 4 5% c'est
normal il veut faire payer 5 et surgit
4e fois justice d'intervenir et te
forcer à faire changer et 1 et ça ce
n'est qu'une baisse de 4,5 ok je vais
montrer genre femme et ton tour la
cavalière 5 g 4 x 6 g5 fait fit le
retour et le purger 5 c'est la fausse
bonne nouvelle parce que ça nous a fait
des trous un peu comme dans le gruyère
français ça fait du trou soit 6 coups de
canif cinglante et heureux événement
c'est en fait tu envie qu'ils soient là
mais dans le monde tu te prends g4 il
repart aussi sec mais l'un au km à
locqueltas t'as pas envie d'avoir servi
les cubains j'ai envie de te dire ma
lynx le lynx
ouais bah lynx lynx assange est en train
de me retrouver le chat youtube sur le
téléphone
j'en profite pour vous remercier à tous
de suivre en notre compagnie ce grand
moment d échecs français fable mais bon
peut être un grand moment qui en appelle
un autre des débats avec avec peut-être
un époux actuel qui se profile de folie
j'ai envie de te dire tout le temps
alors théocrates si vous annoncez prise
g6 d'abord peut-être tb 5 may be on
tourne à un taux crasse qui qui parle
dans toutes les langues qui le connaît
il est parti
alors est-ce que tu prends de hachoud de
f
battus à prendre de l'âge en face à fc
comptant un média qui avait fait notoire
des problèmes avec le 6 oui donc tu
reprends 2h et mathieu qui proposerait
b5 pour venir s'emparer de la case sait
si ce n'est qu'il faut l'admettre on au
quai de la charia des détours ses deux
intermédiaires dire aussi mois des bois
dans les langues
alors mais tu peux aussi faire tour ces
deux directs prête c'est pas si grave la
tour sur baie saint jean
bon ok tu as fait pour cette dame ces
cas tu ferais une case logic et après en
fait sur un sur kf5 par exemple tu peux
concert songer à décaler b4 ou des
changes d'abord on est fluide g 4 cette
fois bien comprend et fluide g leca 3g
de tout rachat en fait dans l'idéal pour
aller mater non mais ça ça m'a l'air de
se tenir
il ya eu ainsi adjugé 4 de la part d'un
bon ok j'ai pensé à la chaîne a tout de
suite en angers 4 c'est fini
comment on this way lors d'it if les
blancs manon et après j'ai 4 bref
forcément ça non mais en fait tu veux
faire autre jeu tout rachat inclut tfc
les gens ça pue pour pour pour le
président de la russie poutine en sueur
ou la gb poutine qui sont en train de
taquiner la bibliothèque la peut
trembler
j'ai des livres qui sont en train de
tomber un dallage et la bibliothèque qui
est taquiner la bibliothèque en sueur
ouais ouais la face au footing ça c'est
en train de mal se passer là je vais
être obligée d'aller d'aller voir
d'aller peut-être intervenir là dessus
non je crois que là c'est très bien pour
max max max havelaar
c'est bien de faire j'ai quatre et ouais
c'est en difficulté ouais et puis qui va
concerner moins de renvoyer au moins
bien autant mais ça peut concept re un
truc un problème est longue ce serait
quand même beau un devoir nepomniachi
répondre à maxime comme ça non mais en
fait si on veut du spectacle c'est comme
s'il ya mieux et du conte en 2000 aux
folies qu'il faut regagner et voilà
ouais avec finalement un époux qui nous
semblé désintéressé du tournant à la
sortie de la première ronde et qui qui
est toujours là et qui est toujours là
bon on voit comme vin parce qu'il n'a
pas encore gagné les gombos slam et max
se rapproche plus en plus d'aider kg 5
commence arrivé du roi judo tout rachat
on l'a déjà dit ça commence à faire pas
mal de menacer les noirs en fait est
dégoûté d'intruction g6 danticat parce
que tu t'es fait ouvrir la colonne âge
temps après faire un pur enjeu soit pas
juste bêtement et ça te prend 10 15 ou
je sais pas faire piéger 6 je ne sais
quoi et ça te fait des trous enfin ça
fait plein de problèmes ça c'est
typiquement le genre de france est ce
que j ai fait moi je joue bien ses
structures avec les blancs avec les
north j'ai du mal et je me sens que
c'est un scénario typique qui arrive
c'est que tu as réussi à faire j'ai
quatre tu passes ta tour et tu mates en
brut à soi et c'est pour ça tu vas que
les a souvent l'impression kashi g5 ses
plus fervents français non mais tu as
quand même de prendre le relais non
c'est dur mais après le voile c'est que
c'est juste très bon pour les soirs ce
genre de trucs objectivement c'est juste
ça peut bien se passer
si les blancs ratent leur attaque ou
booba tu as quoi
oui oui mais là c'est maxime vachier
lagrave enfin j'en veux te dire non mais
juste ok tu peux te dire mais bon tu
juges mal aux gens ce qu'ils fassent
tout jamais une française contre 1
français a fallu dire respecte de toi
mal géré à un moment donné tu
t'attendais à quoi
voilà c'est tout tu vas te la faire
coller tu vas rentrer chez toi afin
c'est une structure française comptera
français pour avoir fait rire en fait
rien à rajouter
voilà c'est à dire que tu parles
gastronomie avec gérard depardieu gérard
à un moment donné faut que tu te rendes
compte que ton bord shooter pelmeni tu
vas pas le poids comme ouais non mais
c'est très bien bravo tu vois mes mais
bon là c'est pas le fasse ou des
asiatiques ou quoi lasser gérard
depardieu
donc ça va le faire faire ça
du coup ils en paient ce qu'ils
reviendront g7 braille obligé pour
sauver son droit mais bon c'est quand à
tfo et fuite pour faire ça quelques
coups plus tard qu'il ya un truc qui
tombe par ont évidemment il est bon il
va éviter de se faire masser trop vite
sur la même chose contre un avis et
surtout à me reste que dans la situation
allait le roi pour les noirs très moche
ouais c'est vraiment j'ai l'impression
qu'il est comme quand on joue contre as
much as tu vas le mater avec les mains
quoi c'est vous il peut aussi passer par
du tour eu trois tours à trois quarts et
faire plein de choses en plus b5 et a de
plus en plus envie de le faire soit 3
maintenant il n'y a plus d'opposition là
bas plein de bonnes choses et qui avait
4 sera avec tempo et tu vois ce que tu
penses que c'est une partie pédagogique
un peu pour l'instant on verra se laisse
jusqu'au bout il ya jim popp sinon ça
donne quoi ben écoute pour l'instant ça
se passe bien
un max max a gagné la première il est
très bien à secondes il doit se
qualifier et après on verra qui va jouer
au prochain tour ça peut pas mieux se
passer fab aînés peau mais n'est pas
elle n'est pas gagné il a un pion non
cette fois il n'a même pas tous mais
il peut y avoir un jour il à l'adar
active
il ya pas mal davantage s'ils gagnent à
5 le premier le pion à sera un problème
je pense qu'il va gagner en fait mais
bon se perdre en retourne tout de suite
chez les joueurs français fab
le mal français qui est qu' à quelques
encablures maintenant de la victoire
c'est du tir au pigeon fab
non mais quelque part talent fou qui
fait du tir au pigeon quoi je sais pas
de quels diocèses d'un pigeon saison
ricou jawid en vue si vous casse de
poutine pour organiser le prochain jeu
plat du russie en sibérie profonde et
sans chauffage va vous apprendre à
apprendre à perdre des matches en quart
de finale maxime qui a joué tour 3 a le
coude le joueur français quoi pour ces
quatre états unis bon écoute gitans de
sa chance à 5 3 et 4 mais en fait non tu
vas te faire défoncer le rhum mais
auquel il tente puisque la fête du coût
de ces d'immobiliser les pièces blanches
un peu la défense 2 5 pouces à des clubs
champions des quatre essais de masse et
qui sait si ça va il fait des coûts quoi
tu peux te tromper que les blancs s'est
pas encore complètement emma l'otan non
mais ça pue totalement enfin tu étais un
peu désespérée quand juste avec les
normes pour l'instant il baisse pas les
armes
vous vous demandez encore que les blancs
jouent 3,3 jouer propre nom mais pas
bête mais bon tu dois faire caler ses
six du coup j'ai une faction du périph
sept noms que bon c'est évident mais
c'est la merde qui est obligé de
reprendre cette tu prends des 4 séries
tu pries quoi en fait mettez malin va tu
as trompe db5 des prisons et des
barrages seul mais là tu as plus de slip
avec les noirs battent encore pour ces
cinq mais oui bon ça va pas non malade
il ya trop de trucs qui ont l'air
vraiment gagnant pour qui rien mais tu
vois c'est en demandait un peu à moins
d'être précis de pas trompé voilà en
plus tu peux faire mais que non mais
clairement mais bon
enfin la le slip va finir salimpoor pour
andré keane j'espère qu'il a dû vanish
ou un truc comme ça ou du monsieur
propre nom mais l'aca affable live à
cette offre ça la vraie s'il bat là je
pense qu'il va falloir l'avait placé
jazz elle tout à me lasser carrelage
plafond et peinture sur les murs ou acer
voilà il va falloir passer à plusieurs
fois quoi ses parents qu'il est de la
javel
il est fort il est fort ce maxime il est
fort il est en train de lui donner une
leçon là bas je pense même qu'il peut
lui faire une facture à la sortie du
tournoi il en aurait pour l'heure de
cours ouais ouais tu t'en tires
peut-être pour 3,4 me laurent andré
quines avec quelques heures de cours là
au moins il comprend pourquoi il n'est
pas dans le top mondial
il a compris que voilà non mais là pour
andré keane cfa y sent qu'il est quand
même tombé sur plus fort non ouais non
mais tu as envie je pense que d'ici avec
le silver cloud ce pas le problème a
réagi le il le sent non il se dit bon on
va pas fou il a impressionné non je
pense qu'il est est sur le cul poésie
bons fous joueurs français beaucoup trop
fort pour moi je pense avoir la
puissance de poutine
rogers dream quoi ouais c'est ça dix
dépôts qui tient c'est plutôt sauf
peut-être qui tient à une époque y tient
on à mais c'est très dur pour ce 20
n'est pour les bleus en fait et soyons
sûr c'est une position que je pense sow
va bien parce que pour eux ça va tenir
avec un ordi mais en pratiquant battre
les blancs les colonnes ils ont les
pièces actifs talent pur à 5 en galère
et c'est vraiment chiant et il va jouer
vite il y avait de la voix sur la
pendule est une erreur et voilà on voit
le scénario arrive on nous écrit dans le
chat le joueur russe bois du smecta cas
pour plates riffier son estomac
ouais
on nous dit +2 83% et votre parti les
gars c'est ça la partie de sauvetage de
83 points levés à la rigueur une
position on va retourner côté les 308 c4
le joueur français qui choisissez
options maintenant mes calculs
parce qu'en fait je pense qu'il ya
tellement de bonnes bon choix peut-on
lire immature et nosy bé 5 + 3 bogeys
sur le flou c'est le cas ici 6 après tu
perds à 4 mais j'ai une histoire de la
combine pour le défoncer des cinq tours
prend 1,4 il a fait qu'à rallier b2 ok
il faut virer le temps
le torse les trois c'est le comte ory de
faire vous paraît trop sur le premier
set mais ok peut-être sa chance
pratiques tu dois tenter ça est à son
tour n va pour les noirs donc pourquoi
pas en faire une
j'aurais tenté sanoflore 10ème pas du
tout c'est vraiment une variante quai
mais je sais pas je n'ose pas s'arrêter
là chance pratique que j'aurais prise
après alors dit que c'est foutu après ça
ça mais bon mais en fait non mais
pourquoi pas vim
il peut il peut très bien faire oui bon
voilà mais tu joues pas tu es problèmes
à long terme mais peut-être maxime roulé
dessus
non mais il va pas jouer pour soi c'est
possible elle al'avantage pour les noirs
c'est que résout pas le problème des
tours f3 voilà bon après tout tous les
autres problèmes c'est l'été les pièces
passive à la défense de 9,7 et tapas
l'espace tu te marche dessus tu as la
deuxième tour qui peut arriver un moment
du roi gedo tour un chien enfin tu
maintiens quoi juste jouant contrôle
c'est pas idiot un statut à ses primes
de ce clip avec les noirs si sow s'en
sort c'est bon bah c'est juste on
repousse l'échéance on n'en sait rien en
fait il s'en sort bine j'utilise s'en
sort mais il y aura des rapides après
encore plus et peut-être des blitz et
être un armageddon
c'est pas ça arrive on a un public très
pleutre en fait ouais tu ne veux pas un
affrontement en demi finale quoi ils ne
veulent pas il ne veut pas le france
brésil
non ils veulent ils veulent du france
arabie saoudite du france afrique du sud
ne veulent pas vibrer france andorre
peut-être et encore on ne sait pas quoi
et à peut-être s'en sortir ce nom mais
il va défendre mais c'est juste très
chiant à jouer et à jamais nulle facile
pendant les positions 5 tours 7 machin
5 en l'air ça paraît difficile mais sow
qui s'arrose au après cinq aux signaux
du roseau philippin c'est la bonne
qualité quoi ouais emporté aux états
unis là il a le stampe trump ça peux tu
vois dit andré qui dans position couches
pampers que j'aime celle ci qui veut
vivre et aux candidats ça on vibrera aux
candidats et à son amour est partout et
tout le temps que fait on est tellement
confiant avec fab
je connais peu et j'arrive parents
d'avoir peur en fait ça le problème mais
c'est très dangereux mais il est
dangereux mais en fait je pense qu'il
est juste moins fort knox en tout
oui mais ferait pas du coup on a eu beau
style 1 mais en moins bien théorique
mais ça va quand même max a beaucoup
donné déjà alors pourquoi lui demander
encore plus cette année balpa nous on
est on est public quoi plus bas moi ça
me fait travailler en fait les gars si
tu veux bosser quoi votre travail et je
vais tous les matins au fort on a du
boulot et non en fait non aujourd'hui
voici deux qualifient pas pour fab depot
gagne pour femme serait génial en
conférence de presse que je les fais
pour faire du business qui mangeait un
trait dessus il a plus de type il a plus
rien du coup on fait quoi je gagne fait
le fait de gagner pour lui alors il a
fait dames 5 tours 7 tours des huit
sachets non mon voeu ça on va pas vivre
sur ce parti mélanie la gagne mais donc
qu'est-ce qui fait le night in d'avoir
tant de temps que sans abri qui n'ont
pas vu le fric c'est que c'est dur de
jouer quand on perd nos maillots qui est
juste ou peur
tu veux dire qu'il faut suivre le
précepte de mire tu as joué à un coût
d'exactement après sa pique hamas est
important il ya geoffroy qui demande si
on peut encore prendre des cours avec
vlad sur ton site
il voulait mais en fait y'a juste pas de
temps quoi malheureux c'est mal me
disait sega qui demandent si kamba
kreuth éloquent via les femmes ont
tendance à s'étaler une action directe
de l'époque
il est des sorties directes contre cam
ce qui n'était pas un premier tour
facile
non non ce que si bon il joue toujours
bien mais à l'époque ni joue encore
mieux sauf ça faisait partie des durs à
cuire très dur à battre au fait très
fort l'américaine ski ça fait peut-être
sept ans là que vous voit plus bas qu'à
bord il fait des tournois je les joue à
gibraltar où il fait il fait des trucs à
droite à gauche mais pendant longtemps
il faisait vraiment les tops tournoi
géré même après sa pause sans fait c'est
un des tout meilleurs joueurs dans les
années 90 notre 90 et 95 me dire et 96
après juste il a arrêté les échecs pour
faire ses études et il est revenue je
pense en 2005 et donc pendant dix ans il
n'a pas joué donc quand il est revenu il
a dû chauffer un peu mais après en trop
entre 2006 et 2012 il allait les gros
tournois en fait les biches kanz il est
pâle et norwich est spécialement mais
les trucs équivalent à ça il n'y avait
pas de conter l'histoire à l'époque
voilà tout ce qui pouvait être gros
tournoi avec carlson nom des crown hic
c'est que il est parti et il est revenu
ouais c'est d'autant plus dur c'est ça
est ok quand il faut et quand il est
revenu il était et est encore très bon
quoi oui et il est encore très bons
aujourd'hui mais je pense à encore
évoluer les échecs depuis son retour
c'est en fait il arrivait à dribbler un
peu 11 ans et petit cela de cette petite
variante à la con
et là je pense il souffrit la main ces
petits systèmes de londres alors qu'il
veut tout reprend à 5 et surtour 3 pour
faire tour ces trois tours france et je
pense que votre tour sur ses cinq
épouses de six et sept finales à notre
gagnante non-match à prendre ce train
non mais en plus tu ab4 qui fera tourner
tu peux faire un coup par la ccpo
invités mais bon du coup je suis
concerné non mais ouais s'il veut pas
mais après même quand on a gagné ici
c'est ce qu'on va arriver à pousser ses
mais bon c'est déjà un avantage très
conséquente à gagner c'est ici stack
tour sur la colonne s'est elle est quand
même hyper forte tu as sidra mettons roi
machin pg une finale comme ça que j'ai
pas gagné mais je pense c'est gagnable
en tout cas tu poseront des problèmes et
à 8 minutes d'avancé à la pendule
c'est pas mal indicateurs quoi qu'ils
sont problématiques pour les noirs oui
oui oui semble que né poa soit favori
dans cette partie mais rien n'est fait
fable pour le moment on va retourner
chez maxime où rien ne se passe pour le
moment andreikin qui cherche toujours à
régler ses problèmes
if he is the way monde sandrine a
proposé nu le bas n'ont pas tenu il s'en
fout perdre ou une séparation
abbas il propose aussi fini mais
pourquoi faire en ville basse et n'était
pas perdants au point d'abandonner quoi
nous a fait faire nul ça abandonné c'est
la même chose
non c'est une panne dans la
retransmission un arrêt buffet je crois
que c'est un plaquage cathédrale
non même si une première retransmission
sont n'y peux rien je voudrais que ça
commence à faire un long moment
ouais
je vais voir sur claude czech non mais
j'ai le coup après qu'il y avait deux
enfants de chasse oui mais du coup ça
peut être une panne
ouais mais c'est une pleine
retransmission c'est mondiale quoi c'est
pas que chez nous quoi alors mbl 5e
classement elo est tout à fait cinquième
mondiale ni 5 ou 4 5 critique est passé
devant prix en b2s griff the kid
ok bon ben il va il part sur un peu
comme time retraite talât en qui tu dois
pas marché mais écoute il prend sa
chance pratiques et du coup ça demande
un peu de précision annuellement avoir
pas inquiet non il ya sûrement plusieurs
manières de jeu extrêmement c'est
marrant quand même grille tchouk qui va
finir l'année en longue peut-être à la
4e place mondiale
c c'est une belle remontée ouais mais
l'offre cirque même dont il avait moins
de lots c'était un mec tu savais qu'il
appartenait à cette caste la cua ouais
mais gère ça fait combien d'années qui
résiste malgré ces quatre mots contre
père de famille t'occuper d'une famille
et tous être complètement sur tout le
temps et maintenir quand même le niveau
aux échecs fois que c'est quand même une
belle une belle performance mais
monsieur c'est parce je pensais pas si
facile que ça vingt quatre enfants c'est
quand même dingue de match de ce mardi
les cinq épreuves sanction d'un match de
tim dowse hommage certes il faut à 3
le tu me fais au débat non
tu bouffes je fais ça tourne turckheim
découvert au matin donc trompé si
stocker pas de temps ces cinq et sept
concerts beaucoup de matériel en plus
c'est très fort ok il faut trouver ça va
quand même sans ça s'est toujours bien
mais c'est pas fini direct des beatles
joué on nous dit dans l'oreillette
c'est sûr c'est sûr fab joueurs français
qui va l'emporter qui va se qualifier
pour les demi finales et maintenant
est-ce que les pôvs à pouvoir lui
répondre en se qualifiant lui aussi où
parents et bien premier à avoir mon
switch rats mais bon ça vous pourrait
déboucher le champagne soit à son
débouché le champagne ici de trois jours
s'est plaint donc saddam h2c la variante
qu'on avait qu'on avait précédemment et
sur cavani f8 fab
on va simplement prendre en 5 et surtout
plus neutre c'est quand même important a
retranché trois oui ça tape à tour g3
pas fait ça donc maxime qui va
l'emporter
ça c'est sûr maintenant on va aller voir
du côté de ceux ci on peut avoir un
dénouement positif n'avait pas car cette
finale mais bon au moins sourire aux
actifs les lattois qui fini ça
m'étonnerait pas que ce soit
objectivement nul mais bon des fois ça
va durer longtemps il va te mettre la
pression la pendule je pense que c'est
objectivement nulle part les règles de
marine un truc c'est que c'est ça c'est
que tu as un but d'avancé avec les
blancs et généralement ça suffit pas
jules auteurs qui me fit side
je travaille pas et games est une
publicité quand même pas trop ça fait
ici c'est ma vie
je viens de féliciter mais en attend à
la fin de max officielle et après tous
ont eu leur adresser de finale plus en
détail on pressent qu'on peut tuer
jusque là on en est où les en indoor
plus mais bon avec tour à attaquer le
tour trop attaquer donc sa victoire 3
féminine on a bien souvent pyrénées
c'est beaucoup
tu as raison faut quand même la regarder
jusqu'au bout des gens là se félicite
bas merci merci ça me touche beaucoup
quoi tu as été discutée le meilleur
meilleurs seconds en pas du tout bravo
pour ta calif
enfin ça va être sympa quand même c'est
à l'admin et poèmes vl ça va être dans
votre compte en tout le temps atos
qualifie maintenant source qualifiant de
mythe normaux - ce sera clair et tout ça
va ça va être un super match fab
bah oui outre un grand dispositif en
place bon c'est le même restera le même
dispositif lettonie doit pas changer
mais ça va être ça va être une heure
c'est un beau match car si vous si vous
kiffez n'hésitez pas à mettre le petit
follow you et saab avec twitch prime
pour aider chasse comme
sur twizz sur youtube vous mettre les
pouces quoi tous les abonnements aussi
d'alain abonnez-vous sur youtube comme
ça vous savez quand il ya des vidéos là
en ce moment il ya surtout du live mais
parfois et les vidéos bajard toute la
série sur andy keane
des fois tu mets des arénas des trucs
aussi non non moi - mais t'as faim tu
fais du ferret mais là il ya eu
tellement de live mvl que ça a un peu
baissé
et ça peut reprendre il ya aussi des
spitfire quelque chose c'est aussi un
tour c'est un jouet alors il veut
rentrer à dans la pollution après ton
france est un fou prend c'est un
cavalier prendre trois fous prendre
trois la gamme trois pions pour la 15e
fois ci c'est ce qui arrive mais tadano
socle auquel vont leurs dix doigts un
truc de ouf j'adore mais il peut trouver
m celle qui avait lieu aux quatre notre
hyper beau prise fois ci est dans ma
chute trop bas blancs pour max ouais
mais du coup il a dû me trouver dès
maintenant
non mais t'as plein de bons coups mais
le cas je trouve ça vraiment beau ce qui
menace est fou prend ses 5es fois
justice donc c'est une double menace et
warfare aux échecs mais non julien chess
me demande au fabuleux card fait que
nous ouvrons info on me l'a proposé me
fais exprès nationalité russe et j'ai
préféré rester
tu as refusé ouais du coup non non je ne
serais pas où est le cas je dois
démentir cette info dans tour serra ya
pas alors il a pris pris effet décade du
coup bon écoute mike keane il fait ce
qu'il peut pour pas perdre direct à son
honneur andré qui disent pas quand même
hein c'est vrai bien mais il se donne
une semaine
il faut aussi en tout bien tout honneur
lui rendre hommage
c'est vrai qu'il impose un vrai combat à
maximin dans ce match
non mais sur leur appartient vraiment
pas clair du tout va du ses chances mais
bong et maxime l'a dépassée dans le
calcul c'est comme ça maxime c'était
chaud et cette partie là on va dire il
se fait dominer
il l'a fait en connaissance de cause oui
il a fait exprès de jouer une forte
partie comme ça ou si les blancs se
plante dans leurs attaques
tu peux gagner plutôt que jouer un truc
solide ou en fait trois heures aux
chances de gain jamais nous a offert un
beau spectacle un beau spectacle il faut
deux hommes et à le russe qui s'est mis
au niveau quand même du français pour
pour nous offrir pour nous offrir ce
joli match donc en tout bien tout
honneur on peut lui rendre hommage
alors côté néo pop c'est quand même
important aussi
ça a continué à tournicoter tournicoton
va-t-il va gagner à 5 15 jours puis on
va passer c'est quand même quelque chose
niveau pendule welsh enquête huit
d'avancé
on va voir les côtés car yakine il
envoie tout quelques millimes 0 c'est
anecdotique mais c'est juste pour geof
c'est pour soi or le dernier carré toute
façon qui va les jouer de l'orgue en
avoir un coin c'est un peu pour savoir
qui va jouer en finale je préférais
quand même que ce soit car yakine que
voter aux aspects semaine puisque karine
il a ses propres intérêts connais peu ne
gagne pas on se bat il a plus aucun
sponsor en fait il est rasé et donc du
coup ici en plus y'a pas vouloir laisser
encore un russe à l'eau candidats
qu'enfin ni ça suffit ces moelleux
l'espoir du peuple cubain fait plus en a
qui passent moins il rate cependant tout
à fait sûr de trouver encore de la pub
pour un aspirateur sur instagram
enfin gères-tu à niveau bulent arinc
c'est assez mal estimé la pub s'effacer
vraiment le niveau zéro quoi baver jarre
quand je reçois ford a pu joindre
inspirateur sur instagram c'est qu'il ya
un problème mais ce sera ma plus on sort
quelques porsche ag plus le lien je
l'avais quelque part mais elle est
incroyable la pub il ne s'est pas parlé
face est impressionnant c'est j'ai
jamais vu un truc aussi ridicule de ma
vie peut-être
c'est quoi le format des candidats c'est
un tournoi double ronde à 8 joueurs donc
14 rondes nice tout genre se rencontrent
deux fois une fois avec les bonnes fées
avec les noirs mais ça en forme attendra
non pas élimination et le vainqueur se
qualifie pour la finale contre aux
carmes scène il sera en novembre l'an
prochain on ne sait pas encore où ces
argentine ou émirats non un truc comme
ça il ya deux candidats argentine c'est
sûr de leur usine qu'ils croient pas
mais j'aimerais bien ce serait beau nom
mais avec seuil et de la passion qu'ont
argentine à mar del plata
non mais je suis assez cool non mais ça
le problème en fait ce qu'ils vont
réfléchir au décalage horaire aussi ni
comme quand je suis en europe
principalement en russie est ce que
c'est pas trop par rapport à l'argentine
à toute époque et on se dira oui bon on
fait marie messier caruana oui si c'est
clair mais du coup autant il doit
décider en fonction du challenger ce
soit ou avant mais je repars avec du
coup c'est dur à dire puisque c'est un
joueur américain des trucs largement
c'est que mes
c'est ce que je veux dire il distillera
l'injure à bab ces quatre habitants des
sept dames tomber cette fois 3 du
dividende homme tu conçois trotte projet
scot et il ya du dôme j'évite 2007 ou
j'ai juste raser le pion oui tu peux
très bien trois excellents et est donc
ça prend totalement fort mince on le
sait on attend la confirmation
officielle
ouais ça va bien se passer un bien se
passer
on nous dit 1 0 alors peut-être que
c'est déjà signé indiqué qu'il est en
train de gagner
il est né peau du cou wen épouse karine
niveau bas niveau ça prend fin en privé
il ferme il convertit il ya le pion à
passer par rapport aux bourses et de
faible hauteur
il va faire du roi dès 5h à 5 à 4 machin
et qui a forcé le toit sacrifier dessus
il s'inclinera sa tour / g à la fin on
fait la même position sont les pions b /
belle chance deux nuls
bon ça c'est au tour à 3 ou quoi mais
légèrement pour ce cas de figure cette
fuite at war dessus mais là maintenant
maxime jolie zéro faim dans la suite ça
risque de faire 2 0 c'est bien pour le
vélo et en plus ce qui est bien c'est
que tu rates j'ai tissé d'étroits le
jardin prend b6 d'alger cet échec
t'as que 8 et toc il a toujours besoin
je suis tu te qualifies ben ça va passer
fabre est ce que ça va passer côté côté
russe aussi pour les peaux bas sûrement
sur une plage très très très étonnée je
vois pas comment guide j'ai déjà hâte en
double hauteur doublement plus c'est
petit adam et fit enfin dit oui je sais
je sais ouais mais ça suffit le tour
nous mêmes ni oui ni non mais vas-y
vas-y vas-y 20 journées
2 / g de tourrades non mais à trop bien
là on est en train de jouer mal
d'exploits gagner si vous montrer qu'il
infléchisse sa joue encore sage ou
encore si ça fait roi g8 avec un petit
piège sur d'un projet
il tente tout jusqu'au bout le jeu russe
est taquin la raison
non mais ils tombent tous battant à ceux
de suttons cas on n'a pas d'autre que
mario gagné les deux sont importants
après la à ce niveau là la partie de soi
importante aussi puisque maxime surtout
qui peut faire nul pour faire nul tout
marche en poésie là cette motion
retourne chez so j'ai l'impression que
ce serait plus salah qui pourrait nous
offrir la qualif du coup oui mais mais
en fait non mais en fait non
ben j'étais en train de me dire genre ça
face à mes trois filles tu prends g4
étude est ce parce qu'ils ont passé de
ce côté partout sarrazin mais une fois
qu'il aura été vraiment précis pour la
gagne et quand même ouais mais en fait
tu sais je sais pas quelle bonne idée
précise j'ai pas trouvé la partie mais
en fait j'ai très très tôt j'ai pensé
que les a gagné juste en pratique elle
joue alors dit et c'est à dire ça va
mais ça va pas c'est pas possible de
tenir précisément tout le monde
maxime il est en train de se rassurer
oui mais vu qu'il a besoin de faire
mieux l'opinion alors dit qu'il faisait
- - - - positif en terre non mais je
veux dire je suis sûr des deux saisons
de serre nul fait [ __ ] en d2
grossistes quoi toi tu fais pas que ça à
faire
pas besoin de jouer pour gagner
absolument oui oui non il va il va
prendre
il va prendre son mii point tranquille
et il a bien raison et donc on va voir
le choc et bien qu'on n'attendait pas
forcément faber pour être complètement
honnête avec vous on s'était dit que
l'adversaire de maxime serait mamediarov
ne paraissait complètement désintéressés
par le tournoi et il va se retrouver en
demi finale face à maxime
attention il continue à peut-être un
jour un d'amasha match tu vois ouais
arrive affaires ou en droit des deux
joueurs français mais méandres équine
qui aura vraiment n'en faut vraiment
vraiment rendre un petit hommage comme
andré kim qui aura joué le jeu jusqu'au
bout et qui est venu remplacer un joueur
au pied levé un des joueurs qui ont
décliné le tournoi pour raisons
médicales il est venu à point leur appui
à pied levé il aura il leur a fait une
belle compétition donc un grand bravo à
un grand bravo andreikin pour pour la
performance quoi et pour pour
l'opposition qu'il a apporté les
émotions qui nous a fait vivre pour le
spectacle pour le spectacle et pas de
maxime qui est content des cours
d'échecs en français ben cool n'a
vraiment je pense une très bonne chose
vous pouvez y aller vraiment sur tout ce
qu'un abonnement sur autre chose comme
vous avez accès à toutes ses leçons et
l'usiné puis ceux qui n'ont pas basse
c'est peut-être l'occasion de songer à
prendre l'abonnement de suaves
mondialement et qui vous offre plein de
plein de choses
où trouver sur la zone de jeu de façon
qui est gratuite tout le temps mais peu
de leurs limites et ça c'est cool que
les podologues cia que l'offre ça existe
maida les analyses de partie après la
partie par l'ordi à tous les articles
bond en a beaucoup en gratuit et quand
même c'est quand même ils sont quand
même sympa et et puis donc maintenant
les vidéos il m'a combien de sang il y
en à 125,25 avec avec avec pour suivre
les leçons des exercices pour bien
confirmer les connaissances sans
l'intérieur tactique là plein de trucs
cool quand à toi et puis d'autres vidéos
qui vont arriver à terme enfin je veux
dire c'est prévu que ce soit garni petit
à petit dans le catalogue wii donc
donc voilà c'est vraiment ça fait un peu
catalogue du coup dis moi vous le sait
maintenant
donc ça c'est sympa dépôt à tous les
coups je crois que même le plus simple
c'est pas la tête et maxime
affaire perpète en fait higgins et un
pénible qua non mais même là dans sa
position soit pourrie il est encore là
une heure après quoi enfin à te faire
des menaces de mathan le 2 je suis
encore des trucs et financier a pas un
code blitz crime alors non sur pias
comme en fait comme comme d'air sur les
vidéos du pion isolés qu'on a fait avec
la de fait il ya une politique de faire
un bon prix en fait de base c'est
d'avoir toujours un bon prix donc
latchès comme je crois que c'est 90
euros par an avec une multitude de
choses donc le prix est très correcte et
de ne pas faire de promotion puisque m
quand tu fais une promo de faim si tu
fais des promotions en quelque sorte
souvent on se fait tout savoir et moi le
premier sur amazon sur machin et tous
est généralement que le prix était trop
fort de base et du coup en fait ils font
ça et c'est pour te faire oui il ya une
promotion et maintenant c'est moins cher
et c'est un truc marketing pour pour te
pousse à acheter la jazz comme du coup
ils ont décidé eux de faire un bon prix
de base est de ne jamais faire de promo
donc c'est une autre politique à court
terme évidemment c'est peut-être moins
efficace mais du coup c'est plus un truc
sur la confiance
donc voilà pour il va gagner en fait ils
échangent et d'hommes oui voilà votre
bien entendu là en fait qu'à la
promotion c'est le vrai prix et tu te
fais avoir quand on achète en promotion
de méthodes le vrai prix il ya comme une
marge pour le vendeur il faut pas tout
vendre à prix je comprends les richesses
comme lui soit 90 euros par an il a émis
140 euros et qu'il faisait mais je veux
vraiment mai
j'aime bien ça je préfère être sur wii
et wii donc nulle signé après d'amd 4 on
nous dit ouais ou alors ya eu abandon et
ils ont mis neuf a beau avoir de
qualification fait quoi ok on attend de
voir si ni pau gan et si nippo gagne du
coup me retrouve en demi et ça va se
passer normalement je ne vois pas craqué
il à belhassen militants plus bon après
ce qui nous fait comme contrat n'en fait
pas un coup sortie de l'espace qui est
catastrophique
ouais mais richie pistes pour répondre
je suis pas employé duchess comme je
travaille avec eux comme femme qui
travaille aussi avec eux mais j'ai pas
employer à proprement deviendront ainsi
des x men on peut tous nous on est
prestataire donc fait moi je fais plein
de trucs partout je les dvd et chaises
base avec jesse j'ai commenté car des
échecs fait plein de trucs sur bitstream
qui complètement indépendant d'ici en
fait ouais c'est complètement
indépendant après presque un comice au
comptant des audiences du travail etc
ils reprennent mais vas-y au cas par cas
mais ce qui permet d'être libre et de
pouvoir travailler un peu n'importe quoi
aussi quoi de voir je veux sur eurosport
aussi oui c'est vrai que j'ai bossé
comme sport bahamas a permis de bosser
avec avec world chaise avec la fidh
avec avec le projet là que j'ai bien
aimé le truc armageddon là qui était
sympa ça permet de travailler sur des
projets diverses quand les gens te
prennes et bien pas moi je préfère de
quoi donc personnellement travaillé
comme ça ne pas être bloqués à 100% sur
un truc est d'être libres quoi c'est
cool non non je préfère aussi après
juste le côté s'est dit c'est que tu es
c'est un emploi stable long terme
je ne dis pas que c'est mieux dans
l'absolu enfin c'est même mieux en terme
de qualité finalement de devoir tout le
temps faire tes preuves dit que si ça va
pas on te dit bombe en fait non pas tant
parce que sans cette garantie
justement et de la qualité du bon truc
pas qu'ils trouvent sur tes lauriers
merde [ __ ] la liberté surtout c'est
cool oui si un jour tu en as marre tu en
as marre qu'on a manqué de faire un prêt
mais j'ai pas de prêt enfin on fait donc
des joueurs d'échecs toute façon
générale il ya rochambeau sinon c'est
quoi le résultat bat maxime est qualifié
mais non il va il va entraîner paula on
voit la potion de dépôt qui est qu'il
faudrait arriver à s'imposer
non mais ça et l'atome n'est pas du tout
dépendant de faim moi perso je suis pas
du tout dépendant de chasse comme en
fait si je parle pas comme demain je me
bats tu fais quoi moi tu travailles tu
fais ton truc tout seul je travaille
c'est pas que de chasse comme qui me qui
me rapporte de l'argent bien loin de là
en fait pas du tout dépendant d'eux
alors attends je suis en train de me
demander à l'enfilade si jolie jolie
fille tu fais quoi c'est une enfilade
non mais ok c'est juste un thème qu'on
connaît qui connut un abandon signait
donc née peau n'est pas qui sera la fab
n'est plus ce sera avec nous dans une
belle demi-finale dans une très belle
très belle demi-finale et max qui est là
où il veut être et qui aura un match
pour la qualif contre un concurrent
direct en fait voilà le un peu le
france-brésil quoi ce qu'on parlait
avant le stream non c'est cool c'est
cool c'est poule c cool cher qu'à partir
de demain on va vivre cette demi finale
couperet un peu bon même si en fait on a
mis ni filet de sauvetage quand quatre
défaites
tu te dis que c'est pas fermé vont
apprécier des points gagne demain je
l'aurais pas s'écrouler ont finalement
plus nom et surtout qu'en finale tout
dépend qui va en finale mais c'est oui
c'est une avarie et donc on demande si
bonne bouille kevin là ça sera là ça
sera encore deux parties donc pathétique
je ne l'espère pas et c'est possible
pourtant c'est possible qu'ils pensent
que les jeux sont confiants en leurs
compétences en partie rapide et que tout
se joue là dessus
ouais alors écoute
non mais en fait ils vont pas se mettre
d'accord avant c'est un fait je pense
qu'ils vont tenter un truc dans
l'ouverture avec les blancs et si à rien
et rien n'y est nulle ici un truc qui
vont tenter de gagner même s'il vomit le
temps est ce qu'il faut au menu soupe à
non non non celui qui gagne le tournoi
il est qualifié de bonus avant ce que la
maxime illac trois points que en fait
avant le tournoi maximale est très gênée
pour neuf donc il a quatre points
d'avance et
et en fait si tu perds en demies battu
marque 3 points et la victoire en
tournant assez vite donc il ya plus que
cinq points d'écart mon cas il passe
devant donc pas besoin de bonus tant par
contre mes beaux objets d'une tendance
pour le coup il peut pas juste ce qu'on
vendait une liste mais pour doit gagner
le tournoi et maxime doit gagner la demi
non là c'est juste salaire global à un
moment assez simple maintenant on a
passé on a passé des mois à être en
difficulté pour expliquer la nature des
pandas de ci de ça des machins là vont
maintenant très vite je pense qu'on est
une petite pub de sortie ok ok kit pub
de sortie et donne rendez vous demain
alors finir de sortie tranquille bien
amusé au dos qui demande encore au final
ce coin de points c'est c5
de quoi la défaite en finale
ouais donc avec le point de bonus après
si ça ferait que +3 et il manque quatre
points donc le point de bonnes idées
ou alors il fait bonus de vie bonus in
vain non ils peuvent faire un bonus
défensif
j'ai perdu en armageddon te donne le
bonus défensif
non mais voilà donc la raison simple si
maxime tu as on gagne demain ça suffit
c'est réglé s'il perd nespouls devront
encore valider ce sens avec une victoire
lors de la finale
et tu sais ce serait mauvais signe tu
sais qui s'intéresse de très près à
cette demi finale à mon avis machin là
alexis russe alexey and co il va
regarder le stream de 20 je lâche une
info demain à l'excès inco sera là il
sera en notre compagnie en pls en sueur
total a pour us et lui sera à fond pour
un dépôt pour la peine et b
en train de prier pour nan contre oui
pour les peaux exactement pour 2008
envie d'être qualifié direct n'a pas
envie de passer par un parent match
contenu police tout ça va être chaud
ouais ça va être ça va être trois belles
journées donc ce sera mardi mercredi et
jeudi à partir de 14 heures moi je dis
ou pas mais bon on se doute que peu à
turin partout quand même donc on se
retrouvera pour ces trois belles
journées et si ces dépôts qui passe du
coup on se retrouvera samedi dimanche
lundi sera le quatrième week-end de
sport la chambre à fond il y en a marre
non que max il se qualifie et que j'ai
le week-end tranquille et noël ça va là
maintenant il ya plus de je veux plus
aller jusqu'au bout là c'est bon on a le
beau match on l'éliminé c'est bien mais
c'est fini mais on fait la fête pour
noël
si vous n'aviez qu'à pas souhaiter la
victoire du beau temps mais on voulait
le beau match mais maintenant qu'ils
perdent graffin le beau match mais on
veut gagner le beau match en tête mais
c'est ça c'est pas le perdre bon sur ce
fable sur ces belles paroles
on vous souhaite à tous une bonne fin de
journée une bonne fin de lundi et on se
retrouve dès demain et avec moi dès ce
soir pour les parties pédagogique lundi
soir peut-être sur la chaîne qui triment
pour le résumer résumé bail